So, Moin Leute, es ist noch früh.
Ich denke erstmal.
So.
Oh Mann.
Zum Glück habe ich morgen noch frei.
Ich bin aber eigentlich schon ungefähr 45 Minuten wach, aber es hört sich nicht so an.
Hört sich nicht so an und fühlt sich auch nicht so an.
So Leute, habt ihr alles gut überlebt?
Von Weihnachten bis Neujahr bis Silvester?
Habt ihr euch die Hand abgesprengt oder nicht?
So.
Ja, gucken wir mal, was 2022 so am Start hat.
Also von, oh ich muss mal kurz Musik anmachen.
Also von einer Sache gehe ich ja mal aus.
Und ich weiß, das ist ein unbeliebtes Thema, deswegen sage ich nur zwei Sätze dazu.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sich Corona 2022 gleichermaßen erledigen wird, wenn nicht erledigen wird.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich es krankheitstechnisch und virustechnisch erledigen wird.
Ich denke, das wird noch eine ganze Weile erhalten bleiben.
Aber ich glaube, dass die Leute das zunehmend ignorieren, weil die keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß haben.
Ja, das ist so eine Sache, die mir als erstes einfällt, wenn ich an 2022 denke.
Also ich denke, es bleibt eigentlich alles beim Alten, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Leute es ignorieren.
Moin.
Death Operator.
Danke für den Sub. Huge Subscription.
Ansonsten.
Ich erwarte für 2022 jede Menge beschissener Games und Games, die weit hinter den Erwartungen zurückbleiben und die Leute enttäuschen, wie sonst was.
Das werden wir wahrscheinlich 2021 fortsetzen.
Ich erwarte, dass Home Office bleiben wird.
Da haben sich einfach viel zu viele Leute dran gewöhnt.
Und das hat ja quasi für beide Seiten Vor- und Nachteile.
Sowohl Arbeitgeber als auch Arbeitnehmer können jetzt quasi fast, jetzt mal übertrieben, zumindest deutschlandweit, fast weltweit Stellen suchen.
Dank der ganzen Home Office Geschichte.
Ist natürlich gut für die Leute, die ein bisschen was können.
Schlecht für die Leute, die nur Windows 3 Fenster anklicken können.
Aber ich glaube, das wird uns erhalten bleiben.
Und was uns 2022 auch erhalten bleiben wird, ist das, was schon vorher der Fall war, aber seit Corona noch mehr, viel mehr Leute online einkaufen.
Die Leute haben sich jetzt dran gewöhnt.
Ich sehe das hier sogar auch bei mir.
Leute, die früher nie im Leben einfache Dinge online gekauft hätten, ohne jetzt eine Begründung dafür zu haben, sind einfach so nach dem Wort, ach nee, ich gehe lieber in den Laden.
Die kaufen jetzt online ein.
Die Leute haben sich auch daran gewöhnt, dass wir doch so bleiben.
Moin Leute.
Ja, warum nicht?
Das ist auch so was, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass der Trend anhält.
Ich gehe ja manchmal in den Bergen wandern und da gibt es ein Dorf mit, da laufe ich manchmal durch, mit 200 Einwohnern oder 260 Einwohnern oder sowas.
Und wenn man da durchläuft, weil ich kann es euch eigentlich zeigen.
Wartet mal.
Mümbris Klein Hemsbach.
So, das ist ein Kaff mit 200 Einwohnern oder so.
276 Einwohner.
Das ist das kleinste Kaff, was man sich so vorstellen kann.
Aber, also wie gesagt, ich weiß das auch nur, weil ich da manchmal hier wandern gehe, hier so in der Ecke.
Und in diesem Kaff ist, guck mal, die Bilder sind von 2000, sind von 2009.
Ihr seht, das Dorf besteht aus quasi fast nichts.
So, mittlerweile sind da fast nur neue Häuser.
Die Hälfte von diesem Dorf sind neue Häuser mittlerweile.
Wie gesagt, ich laufe da ab und zu, wenn ich wandern gehe durch.
Das sind die Leute, die haben keinen Bock mehr auf Frankfurt und sonst was.
Und die ziehen da jetzt hin.
Teilweise Riesenhütten stehen da jetzt.
Von irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Die Hälfte der Häuser ist nagelneu innerhalb der letzten fünf Jahre gebaut.
Und ich glaube, dass der Trend auch weitergehen wird.
Dass sie sich denken, hey, gerade wenn ich remote arbeiten kann, ist das doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Wenn man ganz ehrlich in Frankfurt selbst wohnen ist kacke.
So cool ich das am Anfang fand, so quasi nach Frankfurt zu gehen.
Eigentlich ist es richtig beschissen.
Es ist laut.
Es ist kriminell.
Es hat an jeder Ecke irgendwelche Penner.
Es ist dreckig.
Und Frankfurt hat noch Geld.
Also, Frankfurt hat ja noch Geld.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Frankfurt ist glaube ich eines der Städte in Deutschland, die am meisten Geld haben.
Und sogar da ist es kacke.
Jetzt muss man sich auch nicht wundern, warum Berlin so eine Shitshow ist.
Die haben viele Leute und kein Geld.
Da muss man sich nicht wundern.
Frankfurter, nicht nur dich.
Ich weiß noch, als der Fabian das erste Mal bei mir in Frankfurt war am Hauptbahnhof,
da waren wir damals noch beim Burger King was fressen.
Und der war mega geschockt, was da für Leute rumlaufen in Frankfurt.
Das bist du von Dresden am Bahnhof halt nicht gewöhnt.
Ansonsten sind die Vorteile halt auch nur, sagen wir mal so, materieller Herkunft.
Du bist schneller bei der Arbeit.
Du kannst halt ohne Probleme mal easy um die Ecke in den Laden gehen.
Die Läden haben immer offen und sowas.
Das sind so eigentlich die Vorteile von der Großstadt.
Aber mit Homeoffice und mehr online kaufen, fällt da halt sehr viel davon weg.
Wenn ich eh 99% online bestelle und manche Leute jetzt dazu übergegangen sind,
sogar ihr Essen online zu bestellen, ich habe beispielsweise zwei Kollegen auf der Arbeit,
die bestellen sich seit die hauptsächlich Homeoffice machen,
die sich irgendwie so ein HelloFreshAbo gekauft und kriegen jetzt das Essen zum Selbstkochen geliefert,
ohne dass sie einkaufen gehen müssen.
Denk Peepee, äh nee, Piep, nicht Pepo.
Exzellent, danke für den Sub hier.
Und wieso? Weil euer Internetanschluss zu schlecht ist.
Also ich habe geguckt, das Kaff, was ich euch gerade gezeigt habe,
das hat glaube ich mindestens DSL 16000. Ich hatte letztens mal geguckt.
Ich bilde mir sogar ein, du hast VDSL gehabt.
Und wahrscheinlich auch Vodafone. Vodafone habe ich jetzt gar nicht geguckt.
In der Stadt hast du mehr Auswahl beim Essen bestellen.
Das stimmt, aber wenn du sowas wie irgendwie so ein HelloFreshAbo machst oder so,
dann brauchst du das in dem Umfang gar nicht.
Also ich denke die Vorteile, die Vorteile ob Starlink irgendwas regelt,
habe ich noch, habe ich noch so meine Zweifel.
Vor allem für die Menge an Leuten, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher,
ob Starlink in irgendeiner Art und Weise das Internet für jedermann werden wird,
was da so angepriesen wird. Ich habe da so meine ganz großen Zweifel dran.
Vor allem bin ich mal gespannt, wenn die ersten Dinge kaputt gehen, was dann passiert.
Ja besser als in der Großstadt leben, denken sich sicherlich viele.
Bei mir ist es ja eh wunderbar. Ich wohne nicht direkt in der Großstadt.
Ich kann aber vom Bahnhof innerhalb von 20 Minuten nach Frankfurt fahren.
Möb, eigentlich schon Huge Subscription hier.
Der High IQ des Chats, ja klar, der wird noch größer 2022.
Mehr Subs, mehr IQ Punkt ist ganz einfach.
Ich habe da auch keinen Bock drauf. Deswegen, ich habe es ja schon mal gesagt hier im Stream.
Also, bei mir auf der Arbeit tun sie sich ja mit Homeoffice ein bisschen schwer.
Aktuell müssen sie ja wegen Corona-Richtlinien und sonst was.
Aber sie haben schon durchblicken lassen, dass wahrscheinlich sie es nicht wollen,
dass die Leute Großteil der Woche Homeoffice machen.
So, wenn ich wirklich auf die Idee komme zu sagen, maximal zwei Tage die Woche Homeoffice,
dann werde ich eins von zwei Sachen machen.
Entweder suche ich mir was anderes, wenn es was Gutes gibt.
Wobei ich da nicht so wirklich viel Bock drauf habe, weil, sagen wir mal so,
das Gras ist auf der anderen Seite ja immer grüner.
Weil dort wo ich jetzt bin, weiß ich wenigstens, was mich für einen Mist erwartet
in manchen Kategorien und was ganz gut ist.
Auf der anderen Seite könnte ich auch, und das werde ich auch machen,
wenn die wirklich mit so was ankommen, dass kein Homeoffice mehr möglich ist,
dann werde ich noch mehr Teilzeit arbeiten.
Dann reduziere ich das einfach so weit, dass ich maximal einen Tag die Woche nach Frankfurt muss.
Ich kann mir diesen Scheiß nicht mehr geben.
Und geldtechnisch ist es jetzt ja auch gerade, glücklicherweise muss ich sagen,
bin ich ja in einer luxuriösen Position.
Dank zusätzlichen Einnahmen durch Twitch, YouTube und sonstigen Geschichten
ist es ja auch nicht unbedingt nötig, um über die Runden zu kommen.
Da habe ich es eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber das werde ich mir nicht mehr geben.
Jeden Tag nach Frankfurt fahren.
Unsinnigerweise.
Ja, das finde ich okay.
Einen Tag die Woche finde ich durchaus sinnvoll.
Da könnte man nämlich zum Beispiel sagen,
man macht irgendwie Teamrunde oder so dann an diesem Tag und sowas.
Das ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, finde ich.
Es gibt ja doch Sachen, die kann man vielleicht einfacher besprechen vor Ort
oder sich zusammen angucken vor Ort oder was auch immer.
Also einen Tag finde ich durchaus sinnvoll.
Aber diese Sachen mit, die haben wir dann bei uns, also da wo ich arbeite,
die haben ja immer irgendwelche ganz komischen vorgeschobenen Begründungen.
So nach dem Motto, was soll sich denn der Außendienst denken,
wenn niemand quasi im Hauptquartier vor Ort ist und sowas.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich wette mit euch, dem Außendienst ist das scheißegal,
solange alles funktioniert.
Ich bin aber ja auch kein Versicherungsvertreter geworden.
Und wenn ich Versicherungsvertreter geworden wäre,
dann hätte ich mich nicht beschweren müssen,
dass ich vor Ort zu Leuten hin muss.
Also die Logik verstehe ich nicht.
Und dann erzählen sie noch weiter so Sachen wie,
ja, wir waren schon immer ein menschliches Unternehmen.
Wir waren schon immer menschlich und waren von Menschen für Menschen da und sowas.
Was die immer für einen Blödsinn erzählen.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn, um zu begründen,
dass Homeoffice ja eigentlich schlecht ist.
Richtiger, richtiger Blödsinn, was da immer von sich gegeben wird.
Zumal gerade in der IT, man sieht es,
ich würde mal behaupten, wir kriegen mehr hin,
die Sachen besser hin und für alle Beteiligten auch gesünder hin.
Also verstehe überhaupt nicht, warum man was anderes als Homeoffice machen will.
Naja, also, das kann ich so nicht sagen.
Ich habe das in letzter Zeit nicht großartig durchgerechnet.
Aber wenn ich einfach mal mich ein bisschen zusammenreißen würde
und mich um die Businessseite mehr kümmern würde,
mein Anfragen gibt es ja genug.
Und da sind auch durchaus Sachen dabei, wo ich sagen würde,
hey, da würde ich auch mal ein Playsuit machen oder so.
Da müsste ich wahrscheinlich, aber ich würde da nicht im Geld schwimmen,
muss ich gleich dazu sagen.
Da müsste ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht arbeiten gehen.
Aber erstens will ich das nicht.
Außerdem müsste ich dann Zeug auf YouTube machen und auf Twitch,
was ich nicht machen will.
Und wie gesagt, außerdem würde ich dann eh nicht im Geld schwimmen.
Es sei denn, ich mache richtig mega Stonks noch dabei.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber einen Tag kann ich auf jeden Fall easy noch reduzieren
und ich werde wahrscheinlich nichts davon merken.
Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, wenn man quasi komplett kündigt oder so,
da muss man sich auch selbst Krankenversichern und alles.
Das kommt ja noch dabei.
Haben wir selben Arbeitgeber.
Weißt du was, Martin, ich glaube,
die erzählen alle mehr oder weniger den gleichen Mist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich in irgendeinem Manager-Rhetorik-Kurs
wurden da so ein paar Sachen erzählt und da waren sie alle.
Unsere Manager und deine auch.
Und die erzählen jetzt alle den gleichen Kram.
Die suchen immer Leute.
Ich habe so viele Anfragen schon bekommen für den üblichen Müll
von World of Tanks zu Raid Shadow Legends, aber das mache ich nicht.
Ja, so ungefähr fühlt sich das an.
So nach dem Motto, ja.
Aber wisst ihr, was auch so ein bisschen das Problem ist, glaube ich?
Gerade auf nicht vielleicht unterster Manager-Ebene, sondern so eins drüber.
Ich glaube, die Leute kommen sich daran erinnert vor,
wie überflüssig sie sind, weil alle im Homeoffice sind.
Weil einige immer noch ihre Daseinsberechtigung darüber definieren,
dass sie kontrollieren, was die Leute machen.
Was eigentlich unsinnig ist, wenn man andere gescheite
Tracking und
Sachen wie Ticketsysteme und sonst was hat,
wo man das halbwegs nachvollziehen kann.
Viele kontrollieren immer noch gerne.
Ich frage mich eh, wie das überhaupt funktionieren soll.
Also wir haben ja wirklich ein paar, auch so Abteilungsleiter-Ebene.
Das weiß ich aus anderen Abteilungen.
Die laufen wirklich rum und gucken den Leuten auf den Bildschirm und so was.
Wo ich immer denke, what the fuck.
Richtig.
Das ist halt der Witz da dran.
Ich glaube, den vielen fällt dann so ihre eigene Bedeutungslosigkeit auf
oder ihre eigene Unfähigkeit.
Wenn viel Homeoffice ist und das ertragen sie nicht.
Welche Exchange-Bug?
Nein, der ist mir neu, den kenne ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
Microsoft fehlt aber Exchange, sorgt für weltweite Mail-Ausfälle.
Na, geht ja gut los.
Zum Glück verwende ich weder Exchange, noch habe ich ein Outlook-Postfach.
Was?
Year to Kate, Moment ernsthaft, es gibt den Jahr 2022-Bug.
Ich kenne nur den Jahr 2038-Bug.
Das ist, wenn Unix-Time 32bit nicht mehr ausreicht.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Aber was ist denn der Jahr 2022-Bug?
Zum Jahreswechsel streiten weltweit zahlreiche Exchange-Server.
Die FIP, FS-Engine, Scan-Engine.
Was für ein Ding?
Was ist denn die FIP, FS, Scan-Engine?
Okay, Administratoren von On-Premise.
Das ist übrigens das neueste Trend-Fort seit so 2-3 Jahren.
Es sagt keiner mehr so nach dem Motto, selbstbetriebene Exchange-Systeme
oder selbst gehostete Exchange-Systeme oder vor Ort betriebene Exchange-Systeme.
Das sagt keiner mehr.
Die coolen Leute sagen heutzutage On-Premise.
Oder noch cooler sagen einfach nur On-Prem, weil es dann besonders Cloud-Native-Slang klingt.
Cringe, Alter.
Ihr macht alles On-Prem.
Das skaliert aber nicht richtig Cloud-Native-diagonal.
Also, was ist denn kaputtgegangen?
Administratoren von Exchange-Systemen, die zum Jahreswechsel Bereitschaft hatten.
Nein!
Und werde ich auch nie haben, weil Exchange und Windows alles so aus der gleichen Ecke kommt.
Und ich weiß eine Sache.
Wenn ich es nicht irgendwann mal super nötig habe, sodass ich quasi kurz vorm Verhungern bin,
werde ich mich nie um Windows- oder Microsoft-Systeme kümmern.
Also Azure mal außen vor.
Das ist ja quasi nur die Infrastruktur drumherum.
Aber ich werde im Leben nicht Microsoft-Services administrieren.
Denn plötzlich konnten viele Exchange-Server keine Mails mehr transportieren.
Eine Nachricht dazu, die auf die USA verbreitet sich rasch auf Twitter.
Alles klar, okay.
Konvertieren des Datumswerts geht schief.
Es geht den Menschen wie den Leuten, ne?
Auch super krasse teure Business-Software ist nicht davor geweiht,
irgendwie so ein Blödsinn zu machen.
Es geht den Menschen wie den Leuten, ne?
Auch super krasse teure Business-Software ist nicht davor geweiht,
irgendwie so ein Blödsinn zu programmieren.
Die Anti-Mailware-Scan-Entry läuft beim Konvertieren des Wertes 2.2.0.1.0.
Also 2.0.2.2.
2.0.2.2.
1.1.1.1.1.
Also, ne.
1.1.1.1.
Und wahrscheinlich eine Minute oder so in einen Long-Int-Wert auf einen Fehler,
sodass der betreffende Prozess nicht mehr geladen werden kann.
Allerdings wohl nicht hier.
Ach ja, Anti-Mailware-Scanning deaktivieren, das ist ja ein guter Workaround.
Gerade bei Mails ist es ja immer eine super Idee, Anti-Mailware-Scanning zu deaktivieren.
Und jetzt, ja, das müssen die updaten, ne?
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Moment Leute, Zack, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wir haben ja Exchange auf der Arbeit.
Mal kurz gucken, ob ich noch Mails bekomme.
Ja, geht noch.
Ich bekomme noch Mails.
Gucken wir mal kurz in die Inbox, ob da heute Nacht bei uns irgendwas war.
Einfach nochmal zum Ketten.
Hier eine Menge Zappix-Fehlermeldungen.
Okay, das ist ja nichts Neues.
Nö.
Also...
Also bei mir auf der Arbeit war anscheinend nichts, ich habe gerade nachgeguckt.
Das Anti-Mailware Zeug von Microsoft benutzt eh niemand.
Also den Windows Defender, der ja nicht mehr Windows Defender heißt,
sondern Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection, weil klingt besser,
haben wir auf ganz vielen Systemen bei uns auf der Arbeit im Einsatz.
Weil irgendwelche Microsoft Consultants das verkauft haben.
Die haben da ganze Arbeit gemacht.
Die haben irgendwie den Microsoft Defender angepriesen und jetzt haben wir den im Einsatz.
Wieso steht bei dir bei Twitch noch Backseating?
Weil ich das nicht abkann, wenn Leute Backseaten.
Das ist ja kein Backseaten.
Backseaten ist zum Beispiel...
Weil letztens haben wir wieder ganz heftig gebackseated.
Also letztens wurde wieder ganz heftig gebackseated,
als ich das Welt gelernt habe und irgendwas nicht funktioniert hat.
Und dann chatten irgendwie fünf Leute, die immer erzählt haben, was ich machen soll,
obwohl sie selbst keine Ahnung hatten.
Vor allem, obwohl ich die Sachen schon alle ausprobiert habe.
Ihr wechselt nicht mehr.
Ihr wechselt auf Edge.
Nee, auf Edge wechsle ich bestimmt nie.
Ich bin aus meiner Kombination Chrome, Chromium, Firefox ganz zufrieden.
So, was gucken wir uns heute an, Leute?
Zeigt mal her.
Also das hier wird eh noch lustig in 16 Jahren.
Wir werden es wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil noch erleben.
Ich kann gerade nicht Kopf rechnen, wie alt bin ich dann?
Nicht mal.
53, Alter!
Also mit 53 werde ich das Jahr 2038 Problem wahrscheinlich noch mitbekommen.
Aber die kriegen es bis dahin wahrscheinlich hin.
So, was gucken wir uns denn heute an?
Zeigt mal her.
Warum Mobile Games Werbung so schlecht ist?
Ich glaube, die Antwort kann man ganz einfach geben,
weil sie nicht besser sein muss.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es das beste Kosten-Nutzen-Verhältnis bietet.
Warum sollte man bei Mobile Games Werbung auch zeigen, was das Game wirklich ist?
Mobile Games sehen ja langweilig als Fuck aus.
Sind aber halt voller, wie sagt man heutzutage, so schön Surprise-Mechanics.
Das heißt, du musst die Leute mit irgendwelchem Fake-Gameplay dazu bringen,
dein Casino runterzuladen.
Das ist bei Mobile Games so.
Ja, das wundert mich.
Generell, ganz ehrlich, Windows-Admins kann ich nicht verstehen,
wie man freiwillig Windows-Admin sein kann.
Das ist einfach so.
Zum Glück sind Windows-Server nicht auf dem Vormarsch,
sondern eher auf dem Rückzug.
Windows-Server ist wirklich der allergrößte Bullshit, den es gibt.
Oh, was war das gerade?
Okay, ich glaube, das ist der größte Bullshit, den es gibt.
Man hat irgendwelche Server-Zeuche empfohlen bekommen.
Also, warum Mobile Games Werbung so schlecht ist, können wir uns angucken.
Dann können wir uns debaten lassen vor Level Cap.
Dann können wir uns angucken, 2021 war wild,
und können uns wieder irgendwelche super übertriebenen Simplicissimus-Dinger angucken.
Ja, hat er dann teilweise die Betonung, denkst du ja immer so,
wundern, was jetzt gerade Welt verändern, das passiert ist?
Okay, die üblichen Geschichten.
Elf Spiele haben 2021 nicht überlebt.
Wahrscheinlich Dinger, von denen ich noch nie was gehört habe.
Ich glaube, das will ich nicht gucken.
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe in letzter Zeit nicht,
warum Windows-Tech-Tipps, warum das so beliebt ist.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es mainstreamig genug ist, um sich das anzugucken.
Die meisten Sachen aktuell ziemlich langweilig.
What's running on my homes? Das haben wir doch schon geguckt, oder?
Ach nee, das ist ein anderer Dude.
Das ist ein anderer Typ. Okay, jetzt kann man nachher auch gucken.
Advanced Shit-Techniques.
Ich habe einfach noch die Sachen von letzter Woche auf.
LEGO Creations? Aha.
Irgendjemand, der Half-Life geklaut hat? Exposed. Oh nee.
Wir gucken uns jetzt.
Was gibt es sonst als Alternativen für einen Domain-Controller?
Tja, das ist wirklich das Einzige, wozu ich es verstehe.
Aber es ist ganz einfach, wenn man keine Windows-Clients hat,
dann braucht man auch keinen Domain-Controller.
Aber die Daseinsberechtigung, in dem Fall, verstehe ich schon.
Gerade für so Sachen wie die Personalabteilung,
brauche Windows-Arbeitsplätze und so was in der Richtung.
Ja, da kommst du natürlich all dem Domain-Controller nicht vorbei.
Aber für alles andere brauchst du keine Windows-Server.
Das ist wirklich das Einzige, was mir einfällt.
Active Directory und Domain-Controller.
Für alles andere brauchst du keine Windows.
Es sei denn, man hat sich explizit Windows-Only-Software gekauft.
So was wie... Wie heißt diese Monitoring-Software, die...
Ja, das zähle ich mal zur Active Directory dabei.
Alles, was du brauchst, um Windows-Arbeitsplätze zu managen.
Dafür lasse ich mir Windows-Server gefallen, aber für alles andere nicht.
Wie heißt noch mal diese Monitoring-Software, die Windows-Only ist?
Ja, PRTG mein ich, genau.
Die soll ja an sich ganz okay sein, habe ich jetzt schon öfters mal gehört.
Aus Quellen, ja.
Aber ich würde mir das im Leben nicht installieren, solange das Windows-Only ist.
Doch, gerade die Oma.
Gerade die Oma kommt damit ohne Probleme klar.
Weil die Oma keine advanceden Anforderungen hat, die nicht mit Linux gehen.
Die Oma will beispielsweise auch keine neuen Spiele spielen über Steam.
All mit Anti-Cheat.
Aber wie gesagt, mir geht es ja hier nicht um irgendwie die Oma, was die verwenden, sondern um Windows-Server.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, für was man Windows-Server verwenden sollte.
Außer als Active Directory-Zeug für Windows-Arbeitsplätze.
So, also was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Captain Peng, moin.
Warum Mobile-Games-Werbung so schlecht ist?
5 Minuten, 5 Minuten halten wir aus.
Zeigt mal her.
Warum?
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal gucken, ob die Lautstärke richtig ist.
Es ist zum Lavalöffeln, wo man auch hin navigiert hinter der nächsten...
Es ist zum was?
Es ist zum Lavalöffeln, wo man auch hin navigiert hinter der nächsten digitalen Ecke lauert mal wieder ein schlecht animierter 3D-Sketch,
der mir Mafia City, Game of Sultans oder das nicht.
Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass diese Games, diese Mobile-Games immer gleich heißen?
So fast, was ich...
Fantasy Battle Crowns oder irgendwie sowas.
Die Dinger haben alle die gleichen Logos und alle die gleichen Namen.
Das Spiel mit einem Titel besteht aus einer beliebigen Aneinanderreihung der Wörter Legend, Wars und Dark schmackhaft machen will.
Und jeder weitere von ihnen bringt mich einen Schritt näher Richtung Wahnsinn.
Ich habe bereits über die perfiden Maschen innerhalb vieler Mobile-Games gesprochen.
Lasst uns heute aber mal darüber reden, was deren Werbestrategie so einzigartig macht.
Irgendwo im Internet steht eine Werbefläche zu Verkauf und ein Mobile-Game kauft sie.
Statt aber das eigene Produkt und seine Mechaniken anzupreisen, entscheidet man sich aber offenbar dafür, ein komplett anderes Spiel zu bewerben,
das weder existiert noch irgendetwas mit dem Spiel gemein hat, das man sich im Anschluss herunterladen soll.
Es werden narrative Story-Games mit dynamischen Entscheidungsszenarien und eindimensionalen Frauen- und Männerbild.
Spoiler, das ist keine In-Game-Grafik.
Dann gezeigt physikbasierte Puzzle, in denen man einen Charakter retten muss oder...
Na ja. Und das hat für gewöhnliche...
Was zum... Was bin ich denn da sehend?
Warum ist da irgendwie eine... Was weiß ich...
B oder so? Hat Bleung und muss aufs Klo.
Was ist das für eine Werbung, Alter?
Original gar nichts mit dem dahinterstehenden Spiel zu tun.
Das ist in der Regel nämlich ein Stapel hässlicher Menüs aus der User-Experience Hölle samt Basenbauspiralen und vielen, vielen Wartenzeiten.
Das ist das typische Mobile-Game.
Die sehen alle so aus.
Jedes verschissene Mobile-Game, außer die Ausnahmen, aber die meisten, die in diese Richtung gehen, die sehen alle so aus.
Das ist irgendeine sinnlose... Das ist doch nicht mal eine Städte-Bausimulation, weil das hat ja mit Simulation nichts zu tun.
Das ist irgendeine Aneinanderreihung von Menüs mit irgendwelchen Trainings, Upgrades, sonst was Timed Metern,
wo dann irgendwelche Häuschen gebaut wurden oder Armeen rekrutiert werden oder sonst was.
Kennt noch jemand den Coin Master? Ich bin der Coin Master!
Alles eil, das ist so ein Crep.
Oder auch einfach mal ein weiterer Klon von Bejeweled.
Diese Kontraste zwischen dem vermeintlichen Spiel in der Werbung und dem tatsächlichen Spiel sind so stark,
dass es mittlerweile auf YouTube ganze Kanäle gibt, die die Auflösung dieser Kontraste zum eigenen Geschäftsmodell erklärt haben.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Also, wenn Mobile-Games so erfolgreich sind und mittlerweile mehr Einnahmen erzielen als Konsolen und PC-Spiele zusammen,
warum sind die Werbekampagnen für Sie dann immer noch so schlecht?
Ich glaube, die Antwort ist ganz einfach.
Sie müssen nicht besser sein.
Das ist das beste Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis.
Die Kampagnen sind scheiße, sprechen genug Leute an.
Und wahrscheinlich gerade durch ihre Scheißigkeit sprechen sie auch viele Mobile-Spiele an.
Weil mal ganz ehrlich, die meisten Leute, die mobile spielen, sind halt scheiße.
Deswegen kann man sie mit Scheißigkeit besonders gut ansprechen.
Naja, weil es ganz offensichtlich funktioniert.
Ja, ach wie! Huge! Big Brain Schlussfolgerung!
Weil es funktioniert!
Just do it, forehead!
Weil es ganz offensichtlich funktioniert.
Gardenscapes, das sind in seiner Werbekampagne mit lebensgefährlichen Physik-Rätseln für sich geworben...
Ist doch laut genug, ich habe ein bisschen leiser gemacht, weil es war auf meinen Ohren ziemlich laut.
Genau, sind sie überhaupt schlecht, wenn sie funktionieren? Das ist eine gute Frage, ja.
... aber in Wahrheit nur ein Match-3-Spiel mit Renovierungsthema ist, hat über das letzte Jahr eine Umsatzsteigerung von 78% hingelegt.
Ah, oh fuck!
Alter!
959 Millionen Gardenscapes!
Ich fasse es nicht!
Die machen eine Milliarde damit!
Okay, ich muss doch Sachen abziehen, was die wirklich als Gewinn unten übrig bleiben meinen.
Aber die nehmen 959, die nehmen eine Milliarde ein mit Gardenscape.
Eine Milliarde Einnahmen mit Gardenscape, Alter!
Das ist krass!
Ich mein...
Das geht nur, weil du mit diesen Spielen einfach alle ansprechen kannst.
Das ist nicht Kinder ausnehmen, das ist die Oma ausnehmen, die Hausfrau ausnehmen, die Ultra Casuals ausnehmen...
Die Fortnite-Kinder, die Fortnite-Kinder sind glaube ich eher nicht das, die Gardenscape spielen.
... oder gerade weil es zeitgleich die zweit aggressivste Werbekampagne des Mobile Markts am Laufen hatte und dabei jeden Trick in der Kiste genutzt hat.
Das alles ist also offensichtlich eine bewusste Entscheidung. Die Verantwortlichen könnten es sicher ehrlicher und besser gestalten, aber sie entscheiden sich wohl bewusst dagegen.
Die Frage sollte also wohl eher lauten, warum ist schlechte Mobile Games Werbung so erfolgreich?
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, du musst Fake Werbung bringen, weil die Spiele an sich in der Werbung halt nicht so aussehen, als wolltest du sie spielen.
Und mein ehrliches Fun-Fact, du willst sie eigentlich auch nicht spielen.
Es sei denn, du hast angefangen sie zu spielen und gerätst, weil du anfällig dafür bist, in die Surprise Mechanics Spirale, in die Casino Spirale und bist dann irgendwie addicted auf das Game.
Und die Werbung muss dich dazu bringen, dass du das Spiel runter lädst.
Also um es mal einfach zu sagen, die Mobile Game Werbung muss dich dazu bringen, ins Casino zu gehen, obwohl du nicht ins Casino gehen willst.
Aber wenn du dann erstmal da bist, so die Hoffnung, und das klappt hier anscheinend oft genug, bleibst du da.
Erfolg bedeutet hier nicht immer das gleiche, denn unterschiedliche Werbespots haben unterschiedliche Ziele.
In manchen Fällen ist Mobile Games Werbung nämlich gar keine Werbung für Mobile Games, sondern für werbefreie Premium Abos.
Das alles ist so unendlich nervig.
Was? Hä? Moment, was? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Was?
Ah, die machen Werbung und dann klickt man da drauf und dann kriegt man gesagt, wenn du diese abfuck dumme Werbung nicht sehen willst, kauf dir doch ein Premium Abo.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Das alles ist so unendlich nervig.
Das ist so blöd, Alter.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das nur ein GIF ist und dass sich nur die Download-Seite eröffnet, wenn ich draufdrücke.
Hör auf mich für so bescheuert zu halten.
Das klappt, das klappt bei vielen.
Alter, das ist so ein PP-Garverein alles.
Die richtig fett Geld rein.
Also der Fabian zum Beispiel in Mobile Games.
Ich wüsste, wie viel das immer ausgibt bei seinen komischen Reap-Kiss-Lotterie-Gamestar.
Die eigentliche Marktforschung, die Suche nach den richtigen Leuten, die übernehmen nicht die Werbetreibenden, die übernehmen Facebook.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich immer bei dieser Werbung immer frage?
Aber ich glaube, da haben wir sogar schon ein Video mal irgendwann dazu geguckt, wo das beantwortet wurde.
Was ich mich da immer frage ist, wenn die Games ja überhaupt nichts damit zu tun haben, was man hier gezeigt wird.
Also das ist ja nicht Gameplay.
Aber das ist was, was die Leute anspricht.
Warum macht man da nicht ein Game mit sowas hier, wenn das doch die Leute anspricht?
Und ich glaube, das hat auch schon mal jemand anderes in einem Video thematisiert.
Ich glaube, das haben wir zusammen auch geguckt.
Und es lohnt sich einfach nicht.
Allein schon sich sowas auszudenken und sowas zu machen, kannst du nicht so viel easy...
Das wäre erstens, das wäre Arbeit.
Und das ist bei weitem nicht so addictive und man kann nicht so viel Kram verkaufen, Ingamewährungen,
sonst was wie bei irgendwelchen billigen Farmaufbau, Städteaufbau, Campaufbau, sonst was Games.
Das ist einfach nur, um die Leute ins Game zu loggen.
Das ist die Werbung, um die Leute ins Casino zu loggen quasi.
Wir selbst das Bedürfnis entwickeln, es besser zu machen.
Aber die eigentliche Marktforschung, die Suche nach den richtigen Leuten, die übernehmen nicht die Werbetreibenden,
die übernehmen Facebook, äh, ich meine, MEDA und Google mit den personalisierenden Algorithmen.
Man wirft erstmal eine ganze Menge auf die Bevölkerung.
Wirre, verwackelte Handyvideos, das niederländische Intro, der Gummibärenbande, das Cover der ersten Single von Daniele Negroni und...
Wer zum Teufel ist Daniele Negroni?
Ist das legit? Ich hab den Namen noch nie in meinem Leben gehört.
...das letzte Minion-Meme aus der Familiengruppe und guckt, was die Barrieren bei der Zielgruppe schließlich einreißt.
Das, was funktioniert hat, das wird weiterentwickelt, wieder an die Algorithmen verfüttert und erneut evaluiert.
Und irgendwann landet man offenbar da, wo wir jetzt sind.
Schlechte 3D-Animationen, Plakative, kannst-du-es-besser-Texte und eine größtmögliche inhaltliche Distanz zum beworbenen Produkt.
Wenn man ein Auge offen hält in diesem Panoptikum gebrochener Versprechen, dann fällt einem dieses Vorgehen auch auf.
Das Spiel Merge Mansion erzählt in seinem nicht wirklich schlecht animierten 3D-Spot eine Herleitung für die Spiel-Sorgen.
Das interessiert ja lustigerweise auch kaum einen, ne?
Die Leute, die es dann nicht anspricht, die schmeißt es halt direkt wieder runter oder lassen es gleich bleiben, weil sie es durchschaut haben.
Aber die anderen, die dabei bleiben, die feiern das Game danach wahrscheinlich auch noch, obwohl es was ganz anderes ist.
Und dazu kommt, dass die ganzen Store-Bewertungen eh extrem, wie soll man sagen, fake, kann man nicht sagen, aber beeinflusst sind.
Die ganzen Mobile-Games haben noch so Dinger drin, wie bewerte uns im Store, schalte jetzt fünf Ingame-Jewelen frei und sowas.
Und das machen die. Die geben dann fünf Punkte und da kriegst du fünf Ingame-Jewelen. Super.
Endet mit einem Twist. Die freundliche Oma der Geschichte wird verhaftet, hat aber noch eine wichtige Nachricht in ihrer Hand geschrieben.
Und diese Nachricht ist immer mal wieder eine andere.
Die Verantwortlichen versuchen herauszufinden, welche davon die meisten Leute anlockt und entscheidet sich dann offenbar so dafür, welche Geschichte man eigentlich erzählen will.
Aber wenn man sich so eine App aufgrund der Werbespots tatsächlich runterlädt, dann fällt das doch auf oder spätestens dann ist man doch raus.
Na ja, es gibt zwar schon Leute, die die Apps in den dazugehörigen Stores niedrig bewerten und dabei auf die irreführenden Werbespots verweisen,
aber es gibt auch viele, die diese Spiele trotz der Irreführung spielen, aber sie durch sie entdeckt haben.
Und die niedrigen Bewertungen, die man kassiert, sind wohl offenbar in so geringer Anzahl.
Da spekuliert drauf, dass du mit der Werbung die Leute quasi ins Casino bringst und dass sie dann da bleiben.
Anzahl, dass man sie mit manipulativen Bewertungsstrategien wieder ausgleichen kann.
Also ja, wenn man wohl nur oft genug erfolgreich sieht, dann kommt das dabei raus.
Nicht nur simple Irreführung, sondern manchmal auch dreister Diebstahl von anderen, besseren Spielen.
Vielleicht ist schlecht auch das falsche Wort, denn was Überzeugung angeht... Ja, stimmt, da hat er ja recht.
Das ist mir auch schon öfters aufgefallen, dass du manchmal Werbung hast, wo du denkst, du weißt genau, dass das nicht das Game ist.
Was ist das denn für ein Game? Und da guckst du mal ein bisschen im Internet rum und kommst drauf,
die nehmen einfach eins zu eins Szenen aus anderen Games und sagen dann mit Text-Overlay, das ist unser Mobile Game.
Also du siehst dann sowas zum Beispiel. Du siehst dann sowas zum Beispiel.
Und du machst das Game auf und siehst dann Farmville. Das hat also absolut nichts miteinander zu tun.
Dreister Diebstahl von anderen, besseren Spielen. Vielleicht ist schlecht auch das falsche Wort, denn was Überzeugung angeht, scheint es aktuell kaum besser zu gehen.
Es ist die Evolution einer Werbebranche in wahnsinniger Geschwindigkeit auf den steroiden, personalisierenden Algorithmen.
Das alles in einem Geschäftszweig mit unglaublichen Gewinnmargen, horrendem Marktanteil und geringer Priorität für Medienanstalten, weil der Verlust meist nur verschwendete Zeit ist.
Und nicht zuletzt hilft es Werbeplattformen wie YouTube dabei, Premium-Services zu verkaufen, deswegen das, was vor oder nach einem Video...
Was meint ihr, warum YouTube Dislikes deaktiviert hat?
Das Video passiert offenbar viel weniger moderiert wird, als das, was während eines Videos passiert.
Stellt euch mal vor, was passiert, wenn die Leute Dislikes sehen und sehen, das Video ist scheiße.
Ja, dann machen sie das Video zu und du siehst keine Werbung auf dem Video und ob sie das nächste Video aufmachen, weiß man nicht.
Besser die Leute bleiben bei dem Video, wo sie drauf geklickt haben.
Und das ist furchtbar schade.
Ja, das ist der Grund oder mit der Grund, warum YouTube Dislikes deaktiviert hat. Nicht dieser Kram.
Ich hab's ja schon tausendmal gesagt. Nicht dieser Kram, dass YouTube irgendwie Creator vor Dislikes schützen will.
Das ist eh absolut vorgeschobener Bullshit, den man in der heutigen Zeit gut erzählen kann, weil alle so wahnsinnig sensitiv auf alles reagieren.
Da kann man dann sagen, ja, das ist zum Beschützen der Leute.
Und dann hat man noch welche, die sagen, ja, gut gemacht, YouTube, gut gemacht, dass ihr uns davor beschützt.
Das ist Blödsinn, das hat nichts damit zu tun.
Ich habe ein Jahr lang jedes Klatschmagazin gelesen. Oh nee, ich glaube, das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Wir kriegen Minecraft. Warum kriegen wir Minecraft Videos empfohlen?
Ich glaube, wir haben letztens zwei Minuten von einem Minecraft Videos Video gesehen.
Das Video ist richtig nice. Dann gucken wir uns das mal optional optional.
Heben wir uns das mal auf. Übrigens Leute, wisst ihr, was mir YouTube, ich hab's glaube ich letztens schon mal in einem Video erzählt.
Wisst ihr, was mir YouTube letztens empfohlen hat?
Die eines der merkwürdigsten Sachen, die ich von deren Existenz ich nichts wusste.
Genau Michael fünf Spielern Internet Explorer Chan Season 1 34 Minuten, wo irgendwelche Anime Grills als Internet Browser rumlaufen.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, okay, jetzt habe ich alles gesehen.
Und ich muss doch gar sagen, ich habe es komplett geguckt.
Besser als Battlefield 2042 Gameplay. Ja, schon.
Oh nee, wo wir gerade bei Battlefield sind. Wir könnten uns von LevelCapture Bane lassen.
Wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal was super dramatisches an.
Er betont ja die Sachen immer super über dramatisiert.
Okay Leute, wir lassen uns mal spoilern von dem GameStar Video.
Diese 11 Spiele haben 2011 nicht überlebt. Was könnte es wohl sein? Battleborn.
Was war Battleborn noch mal? Wir gucken uns das.
Das ist jetzt Feifett Time. Wir gucken uns das Video nicht an.
Wir gucken uns einfach nur die Vorschau Bilder an.
Aber Battleborn war diese Overwatch abklatscht von Amazon, oder?
Nee, Moment, Moment, nee, nee. Das war noch was anderes.
Was war? Was war der? Was war der Overwatch abklatscht von Amazon?
Crucible. Crucible.
Crucible, was direkt wieder eingestellt wurde, ja. Battleborn.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was Battleborn war. Es war nicht Paladins. Paladins gab es auch noch.
Okay, kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr. So, was wurde noch eingestellt?
Defiance. Das war irgendein komisches Japan MMO oder sowas, oder?
Was mir nichts sagt. Nee, kenne ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Nostos sagt mir auch nichts.
Sieht aus wie irgendwelche Weep Games oder so. Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Meinst du mich? Ich heiße Battleborn mit Nachnamen. Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Final Fantasy 11 Mobile.
Okay, das wundert mich nicht. Das Game ist irgendwie 15 Jahre alt.
Warhammer hat mich auch nicht gejuckt. Okay, keine Ahnung.
Tom Clancy's Elite. Ist das das, wofür Ubisoft die NFTs bringen wollte?
Ich sehe etwas anderes.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was Tom Clancy's Elite Squad ist.
Irgendein Mobile Game mit schlechter Grafik und Tom Clancy Lizenz.
Was heißt Lizenz? Das gehört ja Ubisoft mittlerweile sogar.
Magic Legends. Das war dieses Hack and Slay mit Magic Zeug, was von Anfang an kacke war.
Wundert mich nicht. Kingdom Under Fire 2. War auch ein komisches Weep-MMO,
was niemand gespielt hat.
Life is Feud. Hä, das ist eingestellt?
Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern? Das war mal eine Zeit lang voll das Twitch-Meter.
So einen Monat lang oder so.
So einen Monat lang haben das alle auf Twitch gespielt. Steam.
Steam Charts.
Ja hier, wahrscheinlich.
Okay, ja gut, aber es spielt ja keiner mehr.
Okay, wurde eingestellt, alles klar.
Das haben wir dann als nächstes.
Hä, der Ring? Was, das Hä der Ringe-MMO wurde eingestellt?
Das ist auch richtiges uralt. Uralt-MMO von 2005 oder so.
Gut, irgendwann ist halt auch mal gut.
Earthbreakers. Hab ich doch nie gehört. Was ist Earthbreakers für ein Game?
Der LKW erinnert mich ein bisschen an ein N64 Spiel.
Kennt jemand noch Blast Corps auf dem N64?
Das war so ein Game, wo man Häuser abreißen musste. Auch mit so einem LKW.
Was ist das denn? Battlefield in nicht Battlefield mit Ingame-Währung.
Keine Ahnung, hab ich schon nie was von gehört.
Ach ja, auf die Frage hin, wie geht es New World? Können wir uns angucken?
New World geht es schlecht.
Es hat ungefähr 5000 Spieler dazugewonnen über die Weihnachtstage.
Unglaublich, guckt euch das mal an. Es ist von 98.000 über Weihnachten raufgegangen auf 115.000.
Also ganze irgendwie 5% oder so.
Die Leute waren langweilig. Was macht eigentlich Battlefield, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Und wer hätte es gedacht, Battlefield geht immer noch schlecht.
Ich meine, es ist hier jetzt ein bisschen hoch über die Feiertage.
Minimal aber wohlgemerkt.
Es ist halt einfach abkacken alles.
Es gab doch nicht mal ein Weihnachtsboost. Der Weihnachtsboost bei Battlefield ist, dass die Spielerzahlen nicht weiter getroppt sind.
Ein nicht weiterer Drop ist gleich ein Boost.
Bei New World ähnlich. Wenn es nicht weiter tropft, ist es wie ein Boost in anderen Games.
Klickmuffs.
Ach komm, wir kriegen gerade ein New World Video empfohlen.
Ah, ne, das kenne ich. Aber das ist 40 Minuten, 50 Minuten lang.
Eines der Sachen, die sehr wrong geventet sind bei New World ist, dass man beispielsweise Kleinzeit-Hit-Detection hatte in einem MMO.
Ihr glaubt es nicht? Guckt mal nach. New World hat das hinbekommen.
Kleinzeit-Hit-Detection.
Wobei, nein, es stimmt nicht wirklich. Es ist nicht Kleinzeit-Hit-Detection.
Es ist Kleinzeit-Hit-Confirmation, müsste man das nennen.
Also wenn dein Client nicht auf Pakete antwortet, wo drinsteht, du wurdest getroffen, nimmst du auch auf dem Server keinen Damage.
Das muss man erstmal hinbekommen in einem MMO.
So schlecht. So schlecht einfach nur.
Ok, wir lassen uns von Levelcap kurz chibaten.
Aber es kann sein, dass ich das Video zwischendurch skippen muss, weil Levelcap ist ja irgendwie dafür berüchtigt mittlerweile.
Zumindest bei den Videos, die ich von ihm gesehen habe, dass der Sachen, die du in einer Minute sagen könntest, in 10 Minuten sagt.
Hey Leute, Levelcap hier und heute möchte ich meine Gedanken über die Zukunft von Battlefield 2042 erzählen.
Ich glaube, es gibt einige wichtige Momente in der nächsten Zukunft, die eine Lichtung auf das, was man erwartet, mit dem Zukunftssupport des Spiels.
Und obwohl wir eigentlich kein Fenster haben...
...wenn wir in die Hintergründe der Behind-the-Scenes-Operation in DICE rutschen, können wir sicherlich ein paar wunderschöne Gäste machen, was da los ist.
Zuerst möchte ich ein kleines Lied aus dem Land geben.
Sie haben in Bezug auf die öffentliche Perfektion ein ziemlich wunderschönes Launch gemacht.
Zwei von den Spielen, in denen die drei Pillele von Gameplay sind, sind mehr oder weniger weggefallen, von dem, was die größere Playerbase ist.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken. Das ist so nervig mit der Musik im Hintergrund.
Was übrig ist, ist das 2042-Base-Game, welches ein paar kontroversierte Veränderungen und ein Lack an Featuren hat, die die meisten von seinen Vorwärtsspieler genutzt haben.
Es gibt einen ganz entscheidenden Punkt, woran man sieht, dass das nix wird. Das habe ich ja auch in meinem Video gesagt, aber der offensichtlichste Punkt ist, Content kommt erst im März.
Und dass sie noch nichts dazu gesagt haben, was eigentlich genau nächstes Jahr kommt. Das lässt mich zu der Annahme hinreißen, dass da allgemein nicht mehr so viel kommen wird.
Okay, ich versuche es nochmal.
Zwei von den drei Spielen, in denen die drei Pillele von Gameplay sind, sind mehr oder weniger weggefallen, von dem, was die größere Playerbase ist.
Das Spiel hat ja... Hazard Zone. Spielt noch irgendjemand Hazard Zone? Alter, Hazard Zone ist tot. Das war nach Release tot. Das hat jeder zwei Runden gespielt, dann war es tot.
Soll ich in Zukunft auch Musik ein bisschen lauter machen bei mir im Hintergrund?
Dass man nicht richtig versteht, was ich sage.
Pupke! Stimmt! Das vergesse ich ja immer. Pupke war ja zum kaufen bisher noch.
Okay, es ist jetzt eine Minute dreißig und man hat absolut nichts gesagt.
Ach.
Naja, das stimmt aber so nicht. Das stimmt so aber nicht. Ja, Battlefield hat vielleicht mit diesem Pay2Play, Firestorm und so bei Battlefield 5 eine nicht so glückliche Entscheidung getroffen.
Aber bei Battlefield 2042 hat man die komplette Kehrtwende gemacht und hat alles eben auf diesen neuen Gaming Trend ausgelegt.
Auf die neuen Gaming Trends und was ist bei rausgekommen? Das beschissenste Battlefield aller Zeiten.
Die sind sich aware, sonst wäre Battlefield 2042 nicht so wie sie ist.
Was? Battlefield ist absolut nicht in einem Decent State. Das ist ein kompletter Abfuck, das Game.
Decent State? Wollen wir mich verarschen?
Naja, das einzige, was bei DICE Decent war dieses Mal ist, dass sie einen Battlefield Communications Kanal auf Twitter hatten und wo dann so Sachen erzählt wurden, Server sind down, wir arbeiten dran.
Das ist aber auch das einzige, was Decent war. Und was man ihnen auch zugute halten muss, dass sie nach diesem kompletten Abfuck zumindest das Naheliegendste gemacht haben, um das Spiel noch ein paar Wochen attraktiv zu halten.
Man hat Rush eingeführt zum Beispiel, aber auch wenn die Maps sich null dafür eignen, dass M-Complacement scheiße ist, aber es ist zumindest halbwegs erträglich spielbar.
Und man hat so ein paar ultra Gamebreaking-Sachen und so nach dem Motto, vom Unsicht-Bug als Bug bis zur teilweise nicht existenten Hit-Detection und Revive-Bug und alles mögliche, das hat man gepatcht, aber das war ja quasi auch unspielbar zum Release.
Aber trotzdem ist dieses Spiel weit davon entfett, in einem Decent State zu sein.
Decent State würde ja bedeuten, das Spiel, so wie es jetzt ist, ist ganz okay, man kann das spielen, ohne sich permanent über das Spiel aufregen zu müssen.
Das ist es aber nicht. Es ist so ziemlich alles, was denn in dem Spiel ist, schlecht zur Zeit.
Die Maps sind kacke, All-Out-Warfare, der Kernspiel-Modus ist kacke, der Content ist quasi kaum vorhanden, was von Waffen bis irgendwelchen anderen Unlockables und sonst was angeht, es ist halt null fertig immer noch.
Ja da können die sich, DICE kann sich jetzt natürlich auch schon mal schöne Weihnachtsferien gönnen, nachdem sie da so krass abgeliefert haben.
Und selbst das, mit März 2022 ist ja irgendwie geleakt von irgendwelchen Data Minern.
Und mich macht es stutzig, dass sie selbst dazu noch nichts gesagt haben, weil hätten sie irgendwas geplant und hätten sie irgendwie schon, weil die müssen ja den Content schon mehr oder weniger produziert haben, die können ja nicht eine Woche vorher sagen, wir machen eine neue Map, wobei.
Also wenn ich mir die Maps angucke, da könnte es schon sein, dass man eine Woche vorher sagt, okay wir müssen jetzt mal einen Season Pass rausbringen, wir brauchen eine neue Map.
Okay, ich nehme das zurück, aber theoretisch würde ich von ausgehen, die Maps entstehen nicht in einer Woche, das heißt die müssten jetzt ja schon was haben und nachdem die so ruhig sind, heißt das meistens nichts Gutes.
Ja, das ist das Leak, das ist halt nichts, das ist halt einfach gar nichts. Meint ihr ernsthaft, es bringt irgendjemand zurück, habe ich ja auch im letzten Video gesagt, es bringt irgendjemand zurück in das Game, weil es jetzt eine neue Map gibt oder einen neuen Specialist gibt, im Kern ist es immer noch der gleiche Scheiß, der gleiche kaputtende Mist, das wird nichts mehr das Game.
Ja Chet, Chet Erks, genau, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre Battlefield das einzige Game im Universum, worauf jeder geiert, es spielen zu dürfen, ist es ja gar nicht, es kommen so viele neue Games raus.
Ich kann mich nur noch gerade erinnern, in Battlefield 5 sollte Firestorm kommen und kam dann irgendwie erst ein halbes Jahr später oder so.
Achja, das ist das was wir an Content bekommen haben in Battlefield 2042, diesen Weihnachtspinguinen, da kann man schon mal zufrieden sein und die Klappe halten bis März.
Und nach Chapter 5 war Schluss, viel zu langsam, ja genau, du musst permanent was bringen.
Das Spiel, ich meine, als hätte das Spiel noch Momentum, sieht das so aus, als hätte das Spiel noch Momentum, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, das Momentum ist quasi das Gegenteil von Stonks, das ist Not Stonks Moment, Not Stonks, ich brauch das Bild dafür noch, wichtig für solche Dinger, Not Stonks.
Wo ist das Bild? Hier. Not Stonks ist das. Das sieht nicht aus, als hätte dieses Spiel irgendwie Momentum.
Richtig, das ist mit die Erfolgsformel für Fortnite.
Und jetzt jetzt vielleicht auch nicht mehr, aber Fortnite hat Maßstäbe gesetzt, wie man das handeln muss die letzten paar Jahre über, da waren die Leute permanent begeistert für irgendwas und das letzte Mal, dass ich sowas in Battlefield erlebt habe, war zu Battlefield 4 Zeiten, wo die Leute dieses High-Easter-Egg gesucht haben.
Da wurde ja quasi jeder Pixel auf der Map umgedreht und sowas. Ich meine, dieses schwarze Loch-Event in Fortnite, das hat jeder mitbekommen, der auch nur ansatzweise was mit Gaming zu tun hat, der musste noch nicht mal Fortnite jemals gespielt haben, das habe ich mitbekommen, ich hatte Fortnite nicht einmal auf meiner Festplatte in all den Jahren.
Was ist das für ein geiler Satz?
Ich meine, das sagt ja gar nichts aus und das ist es im Endeffekt. Ja, DICE hat sich darauf committed oder DICE signalisiert der Community für einen wie auch immer gearteten Zeitraum das Spiel zu supporten. Ja ach, da hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht.
Was ist das eigentlich für Gameplay?
Richtig, da hat er recht. Genau das, das habe ich bei mir im Video auch gesagt und scheiß drauf was DICE, das ist immer so eine Begründung, was ich auch von den Ultra-Fanboys höre, so nach dem Motto, Max, das kann nicht sein, DICE hat gesagt, das ist anders.
Die haben verdammt viel gesagt, wenn der Tag lang ist schon und wenn die heute sagen, ja wir supporten das Spiel für 50 Jahre und morgen sagen ach ne doch nicht und dann, und dann fährt dann jemand zu denen vor das Gebäude und sagt DICE, ihr seid böse, ihr habt mir Mist erzählt oder was, fährt dann jemand nach Schweden.
Richtig, richtig.
Restrategizing heißt das.
Restrategizing.
Also EA könnte sagen, leckt mich, wir machen nicht weiter an dem Game.
Also das muss ich auch mal sagen, da sieht man mal wie weit die an die Realität vorbei sind. Ganz ehrlich, wenn wirklich irgendwelche Manager entschieden haben, ein neues, quasi bei dem Zustand des Games, über das man hätte als Manager Bescheid wissen müssen und quasi mit dem Zustand dieses Games im Hinterkopf dort im Vorfeld schon in Vorleistung zu gehen,
dann ist denen echt nicht mehr zu helfen als auf die Nase zu fallen.
Also das ist der krasseste Manager Fail aller Zeiten.
Wenn man das Disaster quasi intern schon live sehen konnte und trotzdem gesagt hat, ah ja wird schon gut werden, ja das klappt schon, das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Es gibt aber zwei Varianten, was das sein kann. Entweder Realitätsverweigerung komplett, aber dann wären die ja komplett an der falschen Position oder einfach keine Ahnung von dem, was sie eigentlich machen.
Also Gaming technisch und das ist das, was ich eher glaube. Ich glaube, dass wirklich die Manager dort mittlerweile, auch wenn sie für eine Gaming-Unternehmen zuständig sind, nichts verstehen von Spielen und dass die nicht verstehen, ob dieses Spiel gut oder schlecht ist, obwohl sie es sehen konnten.
Da kommt dann irgendein mittlerer Manager Schleimer an und erzählt denen so nach dem Motto, bestes Spiel, das wir jemals gemacht haben und wenn er das glaubwürdig genug erzählt, dann glauben die das.
Ich meine, ich sehe das doch bei uns auf der Arbeit. Ich, oder frage ich mal euch, was meint ihr denn, wenn ich sagen würde auf der Arbeit.
Okay, ich muss mir jetzt mal ein gutes Beispiel, okay, okay. Gehen wir mal von aus, wir würden irgendwie einen neuen Web-Service rausbringen auf der Arbeit.
Was weiß ich, wir sind eine Bank und wir würden jetzt einen Web-Service rausbringen, wo alle Leute irgendwie online, was weiß ich, es muss jetzt irgendwas sein, wo alle unsere Kunden online irgendwie ihre...
Keine Ahnung...
Ihr Kontostand einsehen können oder so, aber das gibt es ja schon. Was auch immer, es ist auch vollkommen egal, was ich sagen will.
Ja, wir würden einen neuen Service rausbringen, wo alle Leute irgendwie so einen Meta-Konto-Service, wo alle Leute in einer Web-Seite alle ihre Konten zusammengefasst einsehen könnten.
So, und mal angenommen, ich würde dann sagen, Alter, die Web-Seite sieht mega scheiße aus. Ich würde es ein bisschen besser formulieren.
Mal angenommen, sinngemäß würde ich dann sagen, Alter, die Web-Seite, so wie wir sie jetzt haben, sieht mega beschissen aus.
Die ist auf mobile nicht lauffähig, die kann keiner bedienen und auf dem Desktop hast du zigtausend Fehler und was auch immer.
Also im Angenommen, ich würde irgendwie fünf Punkte sagen, warum die Web-Seite schlecht ist. Was meint ihr, wie viele dieser Punkte würden überhaupt bei Management ankommen, die dafür zuständig sind?
Und wie viele dieser Punkte wären noch im Original wortlaut?
Wahrscheinlich wenige, wahrscheinlich wenige. Also wahrscheinlich bleiben von diesen fünf Punkten noch ein Punkt übrig und vom wortlaut so gut wie gar nichts mehr, sondern sinngemäß sowas wie, was weiß ich,
manche Mitarbeiter haben Bedenken, nein Bedenken ist auch noch, ich weiß was dann ankommt, manche Mitarbeiter sehen noch Nachschärfungsbedarf bei Web-Seiten-Präsentation.
Das würde oben ankommen. Nachschärfungsbedarf bei Web-Seiten-Präsentation. Wenn überhaupt, wobei das eigentlich noch viel zu negativ ist.
So, das ist das, was oben ankommt und so stelle ich mir das auch vor, wenn du als EA-Manager eigentlich keine Ahnung von Games hast und dir deinen Schleimer-Dice-Manager erzählt,
der ja im Prinzip auch nur gute Sachen, weil sein Job im Prinzip sichert, erzählen will, dir sagt, das ist das beste Battlefield-Game seit geschnittenem Brot, dann glaubst du es dem vielleicht.
Wir sehen noch mögliche weitere Verbesserungen im laufenden, im nächsten Monat, in den nächsten Monaten, ja genau, das wäre noch besser verpackt.
Und umgedreht ist es ja auch so, wenn umgedreht oben einer sagt, wir müssen jetzt XY machen, dann kommt das so auch nicht wirklich an.
Es ist unglaublich, was diese Befehls-Kette aus Nachrichten macht. Leichte Ungereimtheit. Oh, das ist ja auch schon.
Also eins habe ich gelernt. Es ist immer gut, das sieht man ja auch bei Marketing-Stonks-Sachen, negative Sachen nicht mit negativen Wörtern zu besetzen.
Sondern zu sagen, weitere Optimierungen folgen zum Beispiel. Weitere Optimierungen folgen bedeutet ja im Endeffekt, es ist aktuell so scheiße, dass es eigentlich kaum bedienbar ist, deswegen folgen noch weitere Optimierungen.
Also man muss das, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht warum, aber das sehe ich bei uns auf der Arbeit auch, dass die Sachen oftmals so geschönt werden von der Ausdrucksweise, dass du eigentlich die ursprüngliche Message, dass es der größte Crap aller Zeiten ist, nicht erkennst. Mehr am Ende. Egal.
Was ist das eigentlich für Gameplay, was wir hier gerade sehen? Schleiberdude.
So nach dem Motto, du erzählst den Leuten nicht, wenn du es einstellst, in der Hoffnung sie kaufen es noch bis zum letzten Tag. Um sie dann richtig, richtig zu chibaden. Einen Tag später zu sagen, wie du hast unser Spiel gekauft. Nee, das wird eingestellt.
Sobald es eine Überlegung über EAs offizielle Pläne für das Spiel sein wird, können wir sicherlich ein paar Assumptionen über den Lack von Kommunikation oder Weiblichkeit machen, und das ist das, was ich im Januar für schauen werde.
Hoffentlich wird DICE ein starkes Komitment für das Spiel vornehmen, mit einem Roadmap, das ein bestimmtes Niveau von Maps umfasst. Die Spezifikationen sind wichtig hier.
Auch Battlefield Vs Roadmaps hatten Images von Maps und Spezifikationen über den geplanten Content, weit vor.
According to Public Sales Records, Battlefield 2042 has sold better than Battlefield V.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch kein Wunder. Battlefield V, also maßgeblich über gerade Sales die ersten Wochen entscheidet er, wie gut ist die Werbung im Vorfeld vor einem Release.
Und die Werbung für Battlefield V vor Release war einfach abartig unterirdisch schlecht. Ich sag nur, wir stehen, was hat der Typ erzählt, wir stehen auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte und wem das nicht gefällt, der solls nicht kaufen.
Und was haben die Leute gemacht? Sie haben es nicht gekauft.
Und bei Battlefield 2042 haben sie es richtig gemacht. Sie haben eigentlich ziemlich gut das Spiel verkauft im Vorfeld, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das Game nichts davon hält.
Also nichts davon einhält, von dem was da in den Trailern versprochen wurde. Das wird dazu führen, dass die weiteren Sales jetzt garantiert nicht mehr so gut sind.
Das hat sich initial gut verkauft, aber ob sich das aktuell gut verkauft, habe ich so meine Zweifel. Es ist nicht umsonst so, dass es schon einen Sale gegeben hat und ein Free Weekend.
Ich mein, einen Sale und ein Free Weekend. Das Spiel ist wann rausgekommen vor zwei Monaten?
Noch nicht mal.
1,5 Monate oder so.
Die, was die machen werden ist, die werden, ich mein, die haben ja einen Season Pass und sowas verkauft.
Die werden, wenn überhaupt, das Mindeste machen, was sie machen müssen, dass die Leute nichts sagen können, wir refunden, weil Sachen nicht eingehalten werden.
Oder dass sie im Zweifelsfall noch bei den Amis verklagt werden.
Also sie werden das Mindeste des Mindesten machen, wenn sie sich dafür entscheiden, den Support einzustellen, um das, was sie im Vorfeld versprochen haben, zumindest so quasi abstreitbar einzuhalten.
Dass sie sagen können, nee, nee, nee, nee, natürlich haben wir das doch gemacht.
Und wenn dann da steht, was weiß ich, vier Content Drops im Jahr, dann gibt es vier Content Drops im Jahr, vier Sticker, sodass man nicht sagen kann, es gab keinen Content Drop.
Nein, das ist vorbei.
Ja, was ich machen würde, habe ich ja schon mal in einem Video erzählt, aber das ist, glaube ich, nicht das, was passiert wird.
Nein, das wird es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, Battlefield 2042 ist definitiv nicht das Ende von Battlefield, aber Battlefield 2042 ist das Ende für Battlefield 2042.
Da wird nichts mehr kommen.
Also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie Battlefield 2042 nochmal aus dem Dreck ziehen.
Eventuell ist sogar Season 1 die letzte Season, die es gibt.
Vielleicht machen sie noch Season 2 und 3, aber halt nur mit dem Mindestmaß, was sie machen müssen.
Das ist meine persönliche Vermutung.
Aber es wird auf jeden Fall nicht das Ende von Battlefield sein, es wird in zwei, drei Jahren ein neues Battlefield geben.
Vielleicht auch in vier Jahren.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall ein neues Battlefield.
Nein, bist du überhaupt nicht, bist du gar nicht.
Bist du überhaupt nicht, Leute, der ist nicht, ist er nicht, ist er nicht.
Das muss er sagen, weil die ganzen Ultra-Fanboys ihn sonst zerreißen würden.
Ja, richtig.
Es ist ja jetzt schon so, es ist ja jetzt schon so, es ist jetzt schon so genau, was er sagt.
Hätten die wirklich richtig guten Content in der Pipeline, hätten die irgendwas am Start, hätten sie es entweder jetzt schon released.
Das wäre das erste, weil ich meine, du musst ja irgendwie die Leute bei der Stange halten oder Leute dazu bringen, das Spiel zu spielen.
Oder sie hätten zumindest gesagt, Jungs, im Januar das Drop, im Februar das Drop, im März das Drop.
Und meiner Meinung nach wäre das auch noch zu langsam gewesen.
Die hätten sagen müssen, was weiß ich, Anfang Januar wird das getroppt, Mitte Januar wird das getroppt, Anfang Februar wird das getroppt, Mitte Februar das, Anfang März zu Ostern gibt es richtig fette Tore.
Sie hätten das jetzt schon sagen müssen für vorneweg das nächste halbe Jahr.
Hätten sie da irgendwas, hätten sie was und wüssten da schon was, dann hätten sie das auch gemacht.
Und alles andere ist Bullshit, Marketing, Gelaber.
Wir supporten das Spiel für Jahre, kann doch genauso gut heißen, wie wir schalten die Server einfach für fünf Jahre nicht ab.
Also einfach Blödsinn.
Also wir müssen das ja auch mal realistisch sehen.
Würden die Battlefield, würden die es wirklich schaffen, Battlefield 2042 von dem, was es jetzt ist und nach diesem Release in ein gutes Game zu verwandeln,
was quasi ja auch Battlefield im Namen verdient und die Leute es wirklich richtig gut finden und gerne spielen,
das wäre eines der größten Wunder in der Gaming-Industrie aller Zeiten.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man so einfach davon ausgeklangt, ja ja die machen das schon.
Also es ist eher so, wenn das wirklich klappen sollte, wäre das eines der größten Achievements überhaupt der letzten Jahre.
Noch größer als das, was sie bei Rainbow Six hinbekommen haben von irgendwie so einem Crap Game zu Launch zu eigentlich ganz gut.
Und jetzt sagen viele Leute vielleicht nicht mehr so geil.
Noch größer, weil Battlefield 2042 in noch beschissenerem Zustand ist.
No Man's Sky, das wäre fast schon das nächste No Man's Sky.
Also es wäre ein Wunder fast schon, wenn sie das hinbekommen.
Deswegen sind die Chancen eh schon nicht gut.
Das wird, Battlefield geht den Weg von Anthem 2.0, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Aber vielleicht liege ich auch falsch, mein hundertprozentige Wissen tue ich natürlich nicht.
Aber alles andere würde mich sehr wundern.
Was hast du für ein Schreibtisch?
Ich habe gar keinen kompletten Schreibtisch, ich habe mir ein höhenverstellbares Gestell damals gekauft auf Amazon und meine alte Tischplatte drauf montiert.
2021 war zu wild.
Ich muss mir erst noch mal kurz anhören, ob 2 ist Binding ist.
Wir müssen jetzt noch mal kurz zugucken, wie das Schloss geknackt wird.
Naja, sowas hat jeder daheim.
Easy, easy, easy.
Ja, das ist ja nichts.
Wir haben gerade schon Level Cap geguckt.
Hat er auch mal Schlösser gezeigt, die er nicht öffnen kann?
Keine Ahnung, hat er das mal?
Bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Aber nachdem er seinen Channel darauf basiert, dass er Loks pickt.
Na gut, man kann auch Loks picken, ohne sie aufzupicken vielleicht.
Ich bin jeder Meinung, eigentlich muss er das gar nicht mehr machen, sondern da muss die Schlösser einfach nur lange noch anschauen, dann gehen die von alleine freiwillig auf.
Ne, das gucken wir nicht.
Was sind deine 5 Top-Games und 5 Flop-Games?
Da müsste ich mir mal ein bisschen länger darüber Gedanken machen.
Aber was auf jeden Fall 2 meiner Flop-Games sind, sind New World und Battlefield 2042.
Die sind sehr not stonks, auch was Spielerzahlen angeht.
Halo hat mich wirklich positiv überrascht.
Auch wenn die Spielerzahlen da auch runtergehen.
Aber das ist ja normal.
Aber finde ich trotzdem nicht gut.
Die sollten eher hochgehen, aber bei Halo kriegen sie ja auch nicht auf die Reihe, gescheite Anreize zu liefern, warum man das weiterspielen sollte.
Ich müsste erstmal ins Steam gucken, was ich gespielt habe, mir fällt da gar nicht so viel ein, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Leute, ich hab den Fehler gemacht.
Ich hab vor irgendwie 2 Wochen oder so angefangen, Dings hier zu spielen.
Das ist auch so ein Game, das kannst du 4 Stunden am Stück spielen und sitzt dann quasi so halb tot vorm Rechner und guckst irgendwelchen Pixel zu, die über den Bildschirm spammen.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, das geht immer.
So, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
What's running in my home server?
Ok, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Zeigt mal her. Es kann sein, dass wir das skippen.
Ok, wir skippen, wir skippen das.
Ok, erzähl.
Ich, das ist so ein Ding, ich weiß, dass das relativ beliebt ist im Heimbereich und ich weiß sogar, dass wir hier auch im Chat einige haben, die Proxmox verwenden.
Wobei ich nicht so genau weiß, was man im Heimbereich damit macht.
Will man ernsthaft für jeden Dienst irgendeine eigene VM anlegen oder so?
Aber gut, es hat seinen Daseinsberechtigung auf jeden Fall.
Wobei ich kein Fan von Proxmox bin, weil ich weder im Heimbereich ZLFS jetzt so geil finde, noch ich irgendwie Fan von diesem GUI bin.
Wenn ich VMs laufen lassen will, kann ich das mit KVM auch so machen. Im Zweifelsfall habe ich eh eine Linux-Kiste, im Zweifelsfall kann ich auch Wirkmanager nehmen und Remote Attachen.
Und ansonsten mache ich die meisten Sachen über einen Docker Compose-File und starte das einmal und gut ist.
Man kann auch VMWare daheim nehmen. Ja, ESX kostet ja auch nichts.
Weiß gar nicht, ab wann man für ESX was bezahlen muss.
Hier seht ihr, dass ich eine Note habe und KVMs und Stores.
Aber ich bin, ihr kennt mich, ihr kennt mich. Ich bin eh kein Fan von Web-UIs, wenn es um Linux-Geschichten angeht, was Linux-Geschichten angeht.
Ich mache da am liebsten alles über Kommandozeile.
Für die Dienste, die ich dann drauf laufen lasse, natürlich. Na wie soll ich einen Wiki verwenden, gescheit ohne Browser.
Okay, das interessiert mich nicht.
Trunas. Okay, hat er Trunas in Proxmox laufen?
Das sind doch die ganzen Trunas, also wenn ich in das, wie heißt das Ding, wie heißt der Vorläufer von Trunas?
Trunas, Freenas, wenn ich in das Freenas-Forum gucke und Leute sagen, sie wollen das virtualisiert betreiben, haben die da immer einen halben Herzinfarkt bekommen.
Was natürlich schwachsinnig ist, aber da sind auch Leute dabei, die sagen, dass du 10GB RAM für jedes Terabyte Speicher brauchst oder irgendwie so komische Dinge.
Oder waren es 2GB RAM für jedes Terabyte Speicher? Irgendwie so komische Dinge werden da immer erzählt. Das ist kompletter Schwachsinn, gerade im Heimbereich, das ist kompletter Bullshit.
Das ist was, wenn du das vielleicht im Enterprise-Umfeld benutzt, betreibst und dann garantieren möchtest, irgendwie gewisse Mindestbandbreite und Mindestdurchsatz, sowas.
Ne, De-Duplication braucht nochmal mehr. Das ist wieder was ganz wichtig, da verstehe ich auch, dass das viel braucht. Das sind genauso die gleichen Leute, die dann immer erzählen, so nach dem Motto, ohne ECC-RAM darfst du kein Freenas betreiben oder so, was das kompletter Schwachsinn ist.
Warum soll ich das nicht betreiben können ohne ECC? Es wird ja dadurch nicht schlechter, wenn du RAM ohne ECC verwendest.
Du kannst vielleicht manche Features nicht so gut ausnutzen, aber es wird definitiv nicht schlechter, als andere Sachen auch wären ohne ECC-RAM. Das ist fast schon irgendwelche Glaubenssachen ausgeartet, das Freenas-Forum, deswegen bin ich damit auch nie warm geworden.
Außerdem, ganz ehrlich, von dem was Freenas und Junas und was auch immer kann, das einzige was ich brauche ist, ich brauche einen Ordner, der über Samba geshared wird. Dafür brauche ich kein extra Webinterface und dafür brauche ich keine extra NAS-Distribution, die das für mich macht.
Genau, mit ZFS weißt du wenigstens was kaputt ist. Und klar kannst du jetzt sagen, ja, aber ohne ECC-RAM kannst du dir nie so sicher sein. Ja gut, kannst du dir bei anderen ja gar nicht. Also es ist immer noch besser als andere File-Systems in der Richtung.
Also, und für den einfachen Samba-Share brauche ich das ja alles nicht. Okay, guck mal weiter.
Wie funktioniert denn das mit VMs? Ist Junas nicht noch BSD-basiert oder ist das jetzt Linux-basiert? Weil VMs wird also Virtualisierung unter BSD, bin mir nicht so sicher ob man das machen will. Ich kenne legit keine, nichts, was irgendwie BSD als Virtualisierungshost verwendet.
Nee, nee, Jails ist oben drüber. Die können einen echten VMs-Anschein erstellen. Junas ist Linux. Okay, dann verstehe ich das. Das leuchtet mir dann ein.
KVM ist Linux. ESX ist mal ursprünglich in den Red Hat Linux gewesen, aber wahrscheinlich mittlerweile nichts mehr übrig. Aber Virtualisierungstechnisch BSD fällt mir da nichts ein.
Jails ist quasi sowas ähnliches wie Container. Aber anscheinend können die beides, aber es erklärt es ja auch, wenn das Linux-basiert ist.
So, weiter. Weiter. Sync-Zync. Das habe ich auch am Start, aber noch nicht wirklich großartig eingerichtet. Damit habe ich die Hoffnung, dass ich meinen Nextcloud abgelöst bekomme. Zumindest was den File-Zync angeht.
Weil ihr wisst ja, ich bin kein großer Nextcloud-Fan und ich werde es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr werden, weil Nextcloud einfach so ein typisches Ding ist, wie Battlefield 2042. Gute Ansätze, aber kaum was fertig. Und es werden Sachen eingebaut, die ich als Heim-Anwender überhaupt nicht brauche und mich nicht juckt.
Ok, Sync-Zync. Weiter geht's. MacOS. Ja, das darf natürlich nicht fehlen. MacOS-Lobpreisung darf natürlich nicht fehlen, wenn man die ganze Zeit schon mit einem MacBook da sitzt.
Plex? Nee, Plex kommt bei mir nicht in die Tüde. Plex ist für die Leute, die sich Sicherheitskopien von Serien ziehen. Nur Sicherheitskopien von Linux-Images über Torrent.
Kurzumstehen. Ok, was hat er sonst noch am Start? Portäner brauche ich auch nicht. Unsinnig. Ich weiß, es hört sich an, als finde ich alles kacke, aber ich mag es halt einfach nicht. Ich brauche kein GUI, um irgendwelche Docker-Container zu starten und zu stoppen.
Chat, wer von euch verwendet das und was... Ich lasse mich ja da überzeugen. Wer von euch verwendet Portäner und Fenja für was und was findet ihr daran besser als ein Docker-Compose-File oder Docker über die Kommandozeile? Falls es jemand macht.
Weil ansonsten sehe ich da den großen Vorteil von nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Außer, dass ich ein weiteres Zwischenschicht habe, wo ich mich mit auseinandersetzen muss.
Ein bisschen was Grafisches und Logs anschauen. Ok. Ok, weiter. Das ist ein Remote-Gateway. Ja, das habe ich auch schon gehört. Gaming-VM über den Browser. Oh ja, das ist bestimmt absolut krasse High-Performance-Shit.
Gaming-VM. Gaming-VM über einen Browser-Remote. Ist das nicht ein Widerspruch in sich? Also Gaming-VM an sich ist nicht wirklich ein Widerspruch. Ich weiß, dass du mit PCI, Pass-Through und sowas durchaus eine Gaming-VM bauen kannst.
Die Frage ist eher, warum sollte man das machen? Also was ist irgendwie der Vorteil davon versus wir machen dann einfach einen Gaming-Rechner? Es ist Windows.
Und es wird keine Worte für ihre UI gewinnen. Es ist ziemlich einfach. Und es funktioniert für mich. Also das ist mir nicht egal. Es funktioniert für mich, also das ist mir nicht egal. Du wirst wahrscheinlich wissen, warum das so wichtig ist. Es sieht nicht so cool aus.
Ja, das Problem hat man einfach nicht, wenn man das über Terminal macht. Dann machst du nämlich einfach dein Terminal auf, sagst SSH und verbindest dich. Da brauchst du diesen ganzen Crap nicht. Einfach SSH auf alles und Ruhe ist.
Warum hat sein Plex-VM eine GUI? Ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer. Das habe ich mich auch gefragt. Warum ist die Plex-VM in Ubuntu mit Desktop drauf?
Das ist ein Dashboard. Das verwende ich auch als Dashboard. Aber es hat nur einen Grund. Ich habe gestern ein Dashboard eingerichtet. Genau mit der gleichen Software. Warum habe ich das gemacht? Nicht weil ich es brauche, sondern weil ich ja gesagt habe, ich mache mal ein Video.
Was ist auf meinem Heim-Server? So Self-Hosted Tour. Und ich habe mir gedacht, alle haben irgendwie ein cooles Dashboard und die Leute mögen Dashboards. Deswegen habe ich jetzt auch ein Dashboard gebaut, was ich im Stream benutzen kann, nicht im Stream, was ich im Video benutzen kann, wo ich mich ein bisschen langhange.
Ich habe eine Software, die ich am meisten auf meinem Heim-Server verfolgt habe.
Mal davon abgesehen, ich finde es halt komplett unsinnig, solche Dashboard-Software. Warum? Naja, es gibt Browser-Bookmarks. Also ich brauche das nicht. Ich habe einfach Bookmarks oder aber ich bin so oft auf den Seiten, dass schon, wenn ich den ersten Buchstabe im Browser eingebe, in der Adressleiste Auto vervollständigt.
Also das Dashboard ist an sich unsinnig, aber ich habe mir jetzt für das Video auch eins gemacht. Einfach weil es cool aussieht und die Leute Dashboards mögen. So, Nextcloud, eGit, MonkaS.
Guck mal, er benutzt Nextcloud so oft und gerne, dass er es nicht mal zeigt im Video.
Hat er PfSense? PfSense hatte ich auch eine ganze Weile, aber mittlerweile habe ich das, also ich hatte nicht PfSense, ich hatte OpenSense, genau. Ich hatte OpenSense hatte ich auch eine ganze Weile, aber mittlerweile habe ich das komplett eingestampft, brauche ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe die paar Firewall-Regeln, die ich brauche, habe ich auf meinem Router drauf und das sind, was weiß ich, 20 Stücke oder so insgesamt und das war's, brauche ich alles nicht mehr. Warum sollte ich was extra alles betreiben dafür?
Ok, Next, Junas Plugins juckt mich. Windows 10. Man sieht ja, es funktioniert richtig gut mit Windows.
Ok, Huge-Sinn-Los-Video, lul.
Shit-Techniques. Wir kommen uns jetzt an, 2021 war zu wild, auf geht's. Wild. Was hast du gegen Nextcloud? Würdest du stattdessen verwenden? Ja, das ist ja das Problem. So als Gesamtpaket gibt es eigentlich nichts Vergleichbares.
Also wenn du wirklich den ganzen Kram brauchst, also wenn du die Kombination aus Filesync, Kalender und Kontaktliste-Sharing brauchst, dann ist Nextcloud tatsächlich ganz gut, wenn du dir noch ein paar Plugins davon verwenden willst, warum nicht?
Was ich an Nextcloud nicht mag ist, dass es oberflächlich nach einer sehr guten Idee aussieht, aber sobald du dir ein paar Features anguckst, eigentlich nichts fertig entwickelt ist. Nextcloud ist an so vielen Stellen unfertig. Die Suche funktioniert standardmäßig nicht richtig.
Kann sein, dass sich die letzten Versionen, zwei Versionen geändert hat, die habe ich mir nicht mal angeschaut. Die Suche funktioniert standardmäßig nicht richtig, ich muss einen Riesenack machen, bis das Ganze funktioniert. Die Plugins sind alle superbasic von Notizplugins, die nicht richtig suchen können bis
Foto-Apps, die keine GIFs, die keine, was waren es, JPGs anzeigen oder irgendwie sowas. Ganz merkwürdig, das ist einfach nicht bis nicht zu Ende gedacht. Und nachdem aktuell eh der Fokus bei Nextcloud hauptsächlich darauf liegt, irgendwelche komischen Enterprise-Business-Funktionen einzubauen.
Was interessiert mich Nextcloud Talk im Heimbereich? Geht mir am Arsch vorbei, juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Oder irgendwelche komischen anderen Business-Dingern. Ich will auch public nichts scheren mit meiner Nextcloud, ich verwende das rein intern.
Und das machen sie aber schon an sich ganz, ganz brauchbar. Verstehe ich, wenn man es verwendet, ja. Aber also ich für mich sehe den großen Vorteil von Nextcloud nicht. Ich verwende es halt noch, weil ich eben den FileZone verwende und weil ich den
Kalender benutze. Oder auch die Kontaktliste damit. Aber wenn ich das auslagern könnte, würde ich es jederzeit auslagern.
Ja, es hat durchaus Anwendungszwecke. Aber ich mag Nextcloud nicht, dass es eben an vielen Stellen, sobald du es benutzt, stellst du immer fest, ach nee, ist gar nicht fertig. Wir haben es uns auch oft genug im Stream angeguckt, es war immer pain in the ass.
Und das liegt nicht an PHP oder so. Auf was es basiert ist eigentlich ziemlich egal. So, was gucken wir uns an? Wild. 2021 war wild. Wahrscheinlich habe ich die Hälfte von dem, was in dem Video kommt, schon wieder vergessen.
Achja. Weiß gar nicht, wer das ist. Oh nein, Clubhouse. Das habe ich ja schon wieder komplett verdrängt. Ist das immer noch angesagt? Clubhouse? Das war diese Instant Chat, ne, nicht Chat App, diese Diskussion.
Wie soll man das nennen? Voice Chat Raum Diskussions App. Ist Clubhouse immer noch angesagt? Kann man das eigentlich mittlerweile joinen ohne, dass man eingeladen werden muss?
Wahrscheinlich. Twitter hat ja mittlerweile auch sowas, ne? Oder Zug ist am Start. Twitter hat ja mittlerweile auch sowas. Da bekomme ich manchmal irgendwelche Hinweise auf Twitter.
Leute, denen du folgst, sind jetzt in diesen Diskussionsräumen und sowas. Und dann gucke ich mir teilweise Diskussionsräume an und dann denke ich mir, Alter, nur weil ich diesen Leuten folge, will ich trotzdem nicht in diese komischen Räume da rein.
Ich bin noch nicht einmal gejoint. Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung, warum ich das machen sollte. Ist jemand von euch auf Twitter schon mal ernsthaft in so einem Diskussionsraum gejoint, weil Twitter euch gesagt hat, eure Leute, denen ihr folgt, sind in Diskussionsräumen?
Keine Ahnung, ich ignoriert das komplett. Ich glaube, es gibt nur noch ein weiteres Feature, was ich noch mehr ignoriere als sowas auf Twitter. Und das sind auf Reddit diese Sachen mit aktuell am Streamen.
Es gibt auf Reddit manchmal... Mal gucken, ob man das jetzt sieht. Es gibt auf Reddit manchmal zwischendurch immer... Hier, das da. Top Livestream. Ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht.
Was ist der Sinn von Top Livestream auf Reddit? Warum? Das ist so ein deplatziertes, sinnlos Feature. Ich bin auch gar nicht auf Reddit, um mir das hier jetzt anzugucken.
Ja, da hast du Leute, die filmen irgendwie ihre Enten oder so oder ihre Katzen oder machen Musik oder was auch immer. Aber das ist so ein sinnlos Feature, dieses Livestreaming Feature auf Reddit. Und mal legit, ich hätte gar keine Ahnung, wie ich überhaupt in Reddit einen Livestream starten würde. Egal, wir gucken jetzt weiter.
Dazu fällt mir nur eine Sache ein, Leute.
...von Space Cowboy-Milliardären und Reddit-Wall Street-Kriegen zu königlichem Drama und koreanischen Kinderspielen. 2021 war viel zu wild.
Dieses Video ist wie letztes Jahr Teil einer Zusammenarbeit mit Mirko von MrWissen2go. Er hat sich angeschaut, welche... Okay, jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch. Ich verwechsel die zwei eh schon immer. Und wenn die jetzt auch noch collaboraten, blicke ich gar nicht mehr durch. Ich blende das einfach aus, dass es zwei unterschiedliche Personen sind.
Mirko von MrWissen2go. Er hat sich angeschaut, welche Dinge sich 2022 ändern werden. Schaut da unbedingt nach diesem Video vorbei. Großbritannien ist seit Anfang des Jahres ganz offiziell nicht mehr Teil der Europäischen Union. Ein trauriger Tag, vor allem für junge Briten. Ein Grund zu feiern für Boris Johnson. Sein Freund Trump zweifelt auf der anderen Seite des Atlantiks immer noch die Präsidentschaftswahl an. Seine Anhänger stürmen... Ja gut, es hat ja nichts gebracht....kurze Zeit später das Kapitol. Fünf Menschen sterben.
Daraufhin schluckt Trump die Niederlage. Joe Biden wird vereidigt und ist neuer Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten. Doch Bernie Sanders stiehlt ihm die Show und erobert auf seinem Klappstuhl das Internet. Der Subreddit WallstreetBets... Oh ja. GameStop.
GameStop. Ja. Ja. Da musste halt mal zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort sein. Easy. Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Leute das jetzt auch immer probiert haben danach und voll auf die Nase gefallen sind.
Und ich bin gespannt auf meine Mutter's Day-Gift. Ich hoffe, es ist nicht Dogecoin. Es ist.
Wer nicht damit beschäftigt ist, mit Aktien und Kryptos millionär zu werden, hängt wahrscheinlich für ein paar Wochen auf Clubhouse ab. Die App ist auf einmal da und man kann Arafat, Abu-Chaka und Flair dabei zuhören, wie sie Journalisten anschreien.
Die ganzen Assis, Alter.
Bei uns gibt's einen Dönerladen mit Impfstation davor. Also, da kannst du dich doch nicht beschweren.
Ich glaube, die meisten sind sinnvoll und notwendig. Aber was war eigentlich in Düsseldorf los mit diesem komischen Verweilverbot?
Kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern. Alter, Leute, die meisten Casual-Noobs sind einfach so unfähig, ihre Online-Konferenz-Dinger zu bedienen. Es ist unglaublich. Ich meine, ich würde davon ausgehen, ich arbeite in der IT und die Leute dort sollten gewisserweise technikaffin genug sein und das bedienen können.
Aber selbst bei mir in Teams-Calls hast du das Gefühl, die Leute sind irgendwie unter Wasser, haben das Mikrofon irgendwie im Bobble stecken oder so. Das ist ganz, ganz grausam. Ich weiß nicht, was die machen. Aber es ist besser geworden. Es ist nicht mal so schlimm wie am Anfang.
Ich finde das immer geil, wenn die Leute dann sagen, es kommt öfters bei mir vor. Max, du hast ja richtig gute Qualität. Ich habe halt auch ein gescheites Headset. Das wird öfters positiv angemerkt in Teams-Gesprächen, dass ich gute Qualität habe.
Ich habe ja auch ein gescheites Headset, ein gescheites Audio-Interface. Ich habe nicht den billigsten Crab vom Lidl und sitze gerade drauf, während ich mit dir rede.
Das habe ich ja voll vergessen. Das Schiff im Suez-Kanal. Da gab es ja auch 30 Milliarden Meme-Bildchen von...
Ja, genau.
Dafür Karten.
Stimmt. Das habe ich ja komplett vergessen. Das war ja dieses Jahr auch. Hat mich so gar nicht gejuckt irgendwie.
Stimmt. Das war ja dieses Jahr auch. Das habe ich schon wieder komplett vergessen.
Oh, Nathan Fillion.
Alter, das ging mir so am Arsch vorbei. Da hat sich ja gerade so die Yellow Brass auch voll überschlagen dazu.
Das ist mir so egal. Die sollen alle machen, was sie wollen. Das interessiert mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Ach, so spricht man den Typ aus.
Oh, das war es so. Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diese Präsentation oder diese Ankündigung gesehen habt. Ich fand die so hart.
Wir hatten die gesehen von euch. Da hat man am Anfang schon ausgedrückt, ich fand die so hart cringe, Alter. Und so unsinnig.
Alles, Leute, alles fördert heutzutage Hassrede. Alter, ich kann dieses Wort nicht mehr hören.
Wir sollten am besten alles überwachen und alles sperren und alles verbieten, weil Hate Speech vor den Folgen des Klimawandels in sein Metaverse flüchten. Deutschland und Dislikes deaktivieren wegen Hate Speech und der Rest der Welt werden und Chats ausschalten auf Twitch wegen Hate Speech.
Einfach sprechen verbieten wegen Hate Speech. Genau, Chat.
Das stimmt. Ich erinnere mich dunkel, da war was.
Ja, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Okay, nice.
Ja, da war sicher noch einiges mehr in 2021. Die Sache ist nur die ich habe ein so kurzes Gedächtnis für solche Dinger.
Dass ich mir das überhaupt nicht merken kann, was da wie wo gewesen ist.
Nur wenn irgendjemand was erwähnt, denke ich mir, Moment, das kommt dir bekannt vor. Das hast du doch schon mal mitbekommen.
Und dann dann kommt die nächste Überlegung so nach dem Motto Wie lang ist denn das jetzt noch her gewesen?
Und dann kann man so meistens ungefähr noch einschätzen. Ja, eins, zwei Jahre.
Mittlerweile mittlerweile ist es eigentlich einfacher geworden, Sachen einzuschätzen, weil du kannst es in der Regel eingruppieren zwischen vor und nach Corona.
Oder sagen wir mal vor oder jetzt während Corona.
Also wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt, Max, kannst du dich noch dran erinnern, als wir das letzte Mal China All you can eat gemacht haben.
Da weiß ich, das war vor Corona. Das heißt, es muss dann mindestens schon irgendwann wahrscheinlich 2020 oder so.
Oder 2019 wahrscheinlich.
Stimmt, das stimmt, dass natürlich das das weiß ich, das ist auch noch gar nicht so lange her.
Das ist ja erst irgendwie ein halbes Jahr oder so her.
Das war irgendwann im Sommer.
Jaja.
So was haben wir uns sonst noch was sonst angucken können?
Es war nach Corona, genau.
Lego Creations that will blow your mind, da dann zeigt mal her.
Welche Lego Creations werden mein mind blown?
Hey, was geht, Alter?
Das war das letzte Video.
Okay, wir skippen mal vor.
Was für Dinge?
Okay, Moment, ich muss es mal kurz lauter machen, dass es auch versteht.
Was?
GBC Models Great Ball Contraption, also quasi zu deutsch irgendwas, was die Bälle im Kreis fahren lässt oder sowas.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Wisst ihr an was mich das Ding erinnert?
Kennt ihr mal dieses Yoshi GIF?
Dieses Yoshi GIF, wo so wobbelt?
Das sieht original aus wie das Yoshi GIF.
Sekunde.
Fat Yoshi, genau.
Fat Fat Yoshi GIF
Ja, quasi, quasi sowas ähnliches wie das hier.
Alter, mein Meme Board ist im Arsch, das ist zu lahm.
Das da, guck mal.
Es hat doch echt was davon.
Bei Fat Konstruktion.
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das kann am Ende sogar die Papierflieger abschießen.
Also, abschießen ist das falsche Wort.
Raus, rauskatapultieren.
Das ist richtig Pock.
Hattest du nicht mal ein neues Meme Board programmiert? Nö.
Ich meine, das ist schon echt nice.
Guck mal, dass es am Ende vor allem so einen Katapult noch eingebaut hat.
Richtig Pock.
Ich kann mir das original vorstellen, dass irgendwie einer in Minecraft sowas mit Redstone baut.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, das wurde zuerst schon mal in Redstone gebaut und dann hat das jemand in Lego gebaut.
Hat der Kameras oder was?
Hat der da Kameras, die das aufnehmen und dann die Dinger hier auslösen?
Hi fat time, exquisite.
Auch mit Lego Glass für die Linse. Gibt es Lego Glass überhaupt?
Tatsächlich, die verwenden wirklich Lego Glass.
Das kann ja gar nicht aus Lego insofern bestehen.
Ich meine, der Motor ist definitiv nicht aus Lego.
Die Sachen, wo es besonders heiß wird, sind nicht aus Lego. Das ist eine Lego Karosserie im Endeffekt und vielleicht Innenleben.
Die Reifen sind ja auch nicht aus Lego. Ach, die haben wirklich mehrere Motoren drin oder was?
Ich habe noch einen von euch aus Toy Story, die Aliens mit der Klaue.
Das war noch so aus Zeiten, wo ich Animationsfilme voll innovativ und gut fand.
Die Aliens mit der Klaue.
Die Spiele, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es dazu Spiele gibt.
Was soll das heißen? Die Animationen sind heutzutage nicht so kreativ.
Ich denke, dass einfach diese Neuartigkeit und die super Ideen, die du gerade bei den ersten Pixar Filmen hast, heute nicht mehr in dem Umfang vorhanden ist.
Ich weiß, habt ihr mal diesen ersten Animationsfilm mit dieser Pixar Lampe gesehen?
Von 1974 oder so, das ist uralt.
Und das ist für die Zeit echt super, übertrieben heftig gewesen.
Warte mal, das hier meine ich.
1986 ist das hier.
Ich meine für 86 war das die absoluteste Bleeding Edge Scheiß.
Ja, muss ich mal angucken, wie Computer und Sachen 1986 ausgeschaut haben.
1986, Alter.
Ich meine, heute macht jeder Zwölfjährige in Blender das wahrscheinlich in zwei Stunden oder so.
Daher kommt übrigens auch die Lampe.
Daher kommt übrigens auch die Lampe in dem Intro von denen.
Das ist echt richtig, richtig gut gewesen von 1986, muss ich mal überlegen.
Das ist jetzt 1986, man kann das nicht oft genug sagen, das ist fast 40 Jahre her.
Kann man sich gar nicht richtig vorstellen.
Das ist älter als ich.
Nicht ganz älter, fast so alt wie ich.
Das ist so alt wie ich.
Oh, Kogas.
Jawoll, Sudoku.
Was ist denn da drauf?
Kann man das alles mit Legos machen?
Oder braucht man dann irgendwie einen Arduino oder einen ESP oder irgendwas noch zusätzlich?
Oder ist das alles rein mit Lego möglich?
Schreckliche UI-Programmierung, ist das so wie Battlefield Portal mit so Plotten?
Powered by Air, also da im Prinzip sind da irgendwelche Pressluftflaschen drin oder wie?
Das ist keinğimalig von Lego opp.
Das nächste Lego-Kreation ist sicherlich auf der peculiaren Seite, aber ich habe es entschieden, weil ich dachte, ihr werdet es sehen.
Es ist interessant, das Experimentation-Prozess zu sehen.
Das Modell wurde gemacht, um Real-Life Drilling- und Mining-Maschinen zu representieren.
Und während des Videos hat er viele verschiedene Strategien getestet, um in ein Bucket von Lego zu bergen.
Sie fanden, dass ein Puschen-Mechanismus mit Technik-Armen das Beste funktioniert
und sich in den Puschen von Lego-Bricks auslösen kann. Das war wirklich interessant, als ich das Video gesehen habe.
Aber warum?
Nummer 5
Wenn ihr die Perfektion genießt, dann mögt ihr diesen Lego-Kreation wirklich.
Lass mich euch zu den...
Macht das... wisst ihr, wie das aussieht?
Macht irgendwas, was 3D-Drucker-Filament herstellt, was aber nicht sein kann, weil das nicht heiß genug ist.
Bei der Pipe-Cleaner-Bending-Lego-Maschine konnte dieser unglaubliche Lego-Bilder Lego-Mindstorms und Lego-Technik nutzen,
um perfekte Bänden auf einer Pipe-Cleaner, die durch das Mechanismus gerettet wurde.
Eigentlich wird jeder Eingang zu einem perfekten Bänden.
Nummer 4
Warum nicht?
Wir sind jetzt an den Top-Spots in diesem Video, und glaubt mir, die Kreationen werden einfach verrückter.
Dieser hier ist ein exaktes Lego-Mindstorms-Digital-Clock namens der Time-Twister von seiner Kreatur, Han Anderson.
Wir haben in diesem Video eine seiner Kreationen gesehen.
Dieses Modell hier nutzt zwei Lego...
... Lego-Mindstorms-Bricks, die via Bluetooth kommunizieren.
Der Haupt-Kontroll-Brick nutzt die Minute-Digits und behält die Zeit, um richtig zu rotieren,
während der zweite Brick die Uhr-Digits und den zweiten Indikator handelt.
Für mich ist etwas über die Rotation ziemlich mesmerisierend.
Ich würde mich sicherlich gerne einen dieser in meinem Raum als Haupt-Clock haben.
Nummer 3
Wie ich vorhin in der Video gesagt habe, haben wir einen zweiten Lego-Bricks-Sorter zu schauen.
Dieser wurde von der Fantastischen Lego-Kreatur von Filio produziert.
Er sortiert 2x4 Lego-Bricks in sechs Farben, z.B. schwarz, rot, rot, blau, grün, blau und weiß.
Der EV3-Farben-Sensor kann feststellen, ob es noch Bricks in der Queue gibt, die noch zu sortieren sind.
Er holt den Brick, analysiert und erkennt seinen Farben, und dann bestätigt er den Lego-Brick in seiner richtigen Location.
Er sagt sogar, welchen Farben er festlegt.
Also, hör auf.
Easy.
Da fand ich den ersten Sorter aber cooler.
Ja, ich hoffe, der macht mal Sound an.
Wie?
Wenn ich mal etwas vorgespielt habe, dann bezweifle ich, dass es richtig funktioniert.
Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Weil, so Dinger gibt es ja schon, und solange man das nicht mit Lego-Sachen dann baut, also auch von der Logik her,
ist das ja eigentlich kein großer Unterschied, ob man das jetzt mit Lego baut oder mit irgendwas anderem baut.
Solange man eben Software, Kamera und das ganze Zeug von Lego baut,
ist das ja eigentlich kein großer Unterschied, ob man das jetzt mit Lego baut oder mit irgendwas anderem baut,
solange man eben Software, Kamera und das ganze Zeug von Lego baut.
Ich meine, klar, es mag vielleicht ein bisschen herausfordernder sein, weil Lego nicht so stabil ist,
aber so Dinger gibt es ja schon in allen erdenklichen Varianten.
Es hat halt einer mit Lego gebaut.
Wobei das von der Mechanik her natürlich schon eine gewisse Herausforderung in Lego ist.
Was hast du an Sylvester Alt getroffen?
Ich muss sagen, die ersten drei oder so waren eigentlich am besten.
So, schauen wir mal, was schlägt uns YouTube denn noch vor?
Ich will das Video nicht gucken, YouTube, du hast es das letzte Mal schon immer vorgeschlagen.
Bankrott im Teletext.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, schon mal geguckt.
Das letzte Video untab, ich habe ein Jahr lang jedes Klatschblatt gelesen.
Sollen wir das so? Okay, weil ihr sidechat.
Jedes. Kann man wirklich, ich meine, es gibt verdammt viele davon, oder?
Das schlimmste, was ich mal an Yellowpress überschrift gelesen habe, ist,
ich sage jetzt mal irgendwie, was weiß ich, Prinzessin Stephanie,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es eine Prinzessin Stephanie gibt, aber Prinzessin Stephanie,
ein Schuster gibt ihr halt, stand da so als Titel.
Und da denkt man so, Alter, die ist mit einem Schuster fremdgegangen oder so.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist wortwörtlich das passiert, der hat ihr ein paar neue Schuhe gebaut.
Also ist die Überschrift nicht falsch gewesen.
Aber das waren quasi, also die Vorreiter, die sind Vorreiter für Clickbait gewesen.
Die haben schon Clickbait gemacht, als das Wort Clickbait noch nicht erfunden wurde.
Bisschen leise.
Bisschen dumme Idee, was würde passieren, wenn man ein Jahr lang jedes Katschmagazin ist.
Also wirklich jedes Magazin, jede Ausgabe, um dann am Ende des Jahres
einen großen Jahresrückblick für die Stars zu machen.
Denn das Leben dieser Stars ist ja eine absolute Achterbahn.
Wie das, was in diesem Magazin steht, ist immer nur gelogen.
Ja, okay, dass das alles Lügen sind, das wissen wir.
Ich sage, das ist Clickbait, bevor man das Wort Clickbait kannte.
Alle, aber wie absurd ist es denn genau?
Das wollte ich mal rausfinden.
Es hat damals angefangen, weil wir diese beiden Magazine zufällig im Regal nebeneinander gesehen hatten.
Schlimmste Befürchtungen, die Ärzte von Michael Schumacher geben auf.
Und direkt daneben, er hat es geschafft.
Ja, wir sehen Schumi wieder.
Diese beiden Zeitschriften.
Okay, das ist schon ziemlich fail.
Die beiden sind am selben Tag erschienen.
Was für ein Auf und Ab der Gefühle.
Und ich weiß, dass Jan Böhmermann inzwischen auch ein sehr gutes Video zu diesem Thema gemacht hat.
Aber ich mache es etwas anders.
Ich habe wirklich ein Jahr lang jede Ausgabe von jedem Magazin gelesen.
Ja, okay, dann komm mal her.
Das ist Masha, sie machte gerade einen Praktikum.
Und ratet mal, was meine Aufgabe war.
Also ich habe ein Jahr lang jede dieser Magazine gelesen.
Und ich habe ein Jahr lang jede dieser Magazine gelesen.
Und nicht fünf.
Real life weird champs.
Praktikantinnen, die ich über das Jahr hinweg dazu gezwungen habe.
Aber es war es wert, denn ich will dieses Video seit sechs Jahren machen.
Seitdem ich damals auf das hier gestoßen bin.
Freizeit-Mohle.
Freizeit-Pitz.
Freizeit-Heute.
Freizeit-Exzesiv.
Freizeit-Version.
Warum heißt das alles Freizeit?
Freizeit pur.
Gute Freizeit.
Freizeit direkt.
Es gibt kein Witz.
Freizeit Revue.
Freizeit Momente.
Freizeit Illustrierte.
Freizeit Spaß.
Freizeit aktiv.
Freizeit Blatt.
Freizeit Schiff.
Das ist doch alles das gleiche.
Das ist auch alles das gleiche Logo, oder?
Das ist doch alles der gleiche Laden.
Die haben bestimmt im Hintergrund einfach so einen Text.
Baustein Randomizer.
Der den Scheiß zusammenbaut.
Freizeit-Begnügen.
Freizeit-Express.
Freizeit-König.
Freizeit aktuell.
Freizeit live.
Freizeit direkt.
Freizeit heute.
Ich mein, das ist auch...
Du siehst halt auch gleich an was ihr das richtet.
Freizeit Woche, so wie das.
Das ist für die Generation 70 plus.
60, 70 plus, ja.
Das ist Clickbait, bevor Clickbait den Namen Clickbait hatte.
Freizeit.
Freizeit Monat.
Freizeit Post.
Freizeit exklusiv.
Schöne Freizeit.
Prima Freizeit.
Freizeit im Glück.
Freizeit im Blick.
Freizeit für mich.
Freizeit für meinen Tag.
Und der Kram aus dem Tag.
Du Scheiße.
Freizeit Schlager.
Freizeit pur.
Neue Freizeit.
Gute Freizeit.
Freizeit im Leben.
Freizeit erleben.
Freizeit Spezial.
Freizeit Ressel.
Freizeit Idee.
Freizeit total.
Also ich persönlich würde Freizeit Schlager bevorzugen.
Das ist doch alles der gleiche Scheiß.
Nur, dass das quasi die Textbaustein neu zusammengesetzt wird.
Und als Bonus, Freizeit Woche Royal Baby, Freizeit Revue Royal und auch noch Freizeit Revue Roskops.
Es gibt, soweit ich das recherchiert habe, über 40 Magazine, die regelmäßig erscheinen.
Manche davon wöchentlich, von unterschiedlichen Verlagen.
Und das sind ja jetzt nur die gewesen, die Freizeit im Titel haben.
Es gibt ja noch zig andere.
Zum Beispiel.
Schöne Woche.
Super Woche.
Revue der Woche.
Prima Woche.
Neue Woche.
Meine Woche.
Illuder Woche.
Jungs Woche.
Der Frauenwoche aktuell.
Wer kauft das alles?
Ich mein, alles das muss zumindest noch gedruckt werden und vertrieben werden.
Auch wenn die Storys randomized sind.
Von einem, keine Ahnung, Dreier-Team, die 40 Zeitungen rausbringen.
Aber das kostet doch Geld.
Das heißt, das muss irgendwie wieder reinkommen.
XXL-Woche und eine Woche Pause.
Die brauchen wir alle.
Na gut, das ist halt für 60 plus.
Die kaufen doch solche Zeitungen.
Ich bin ein Spiegel.
Echo der Frau.
Okay, eins noch.
Blatt.
Spaß.
Man kann es gar nicht glauben.
Und trotz immensen Praktikanten-Support war es am Ende vielleicht ein bisschen überambitioniert,
wirklich jede Ausgabe von jedem dieser Magazine ein Jahr lesen zu wollen.
Also haben wir uns am Ende auf 20 unterschiedliche Zeitschriften beschränkt
und von denen dann jede Ausgabe gelesen.
Aber ich sag's euch, das hat mehr als gereicht.
Lesen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, kann man das überhaupt lesen nennen?
Das alles ist.
Über Medien, die zu dem Thema auch ganz, ganz tolle Artikel regelmäßig schreiben,
kann ich euch sehr empfehlen, die mal auszuchecken.
Die haben zu Helene Fischer mal nachgezählt.
Und da erscheinen pro Jahr über 1000 Geschichten über sie.
Geschichten wie die hier aus dem Juni.
Drama um ihre Eltern.
Am See spielen sich furchtbare Zielen ab.
Oh Gott, was ist da passiert?
Wahrscheinlich nichts.
An dem ihre Eltern leben, gibt's Mücken.
Oh nein.
Wie die Eltern um sich schlagen, um die Mücken zu verscheuchen.
Wobei, wobei, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Man kann sich jetzt zwar drüber lustig machen,
aber man darf sich nicht einbilden.
Das wäre auf YouTube irgendwie anders.
Guckt euch die erfolgreichen YouTube Click-Bait-Geschichten an.
Das ist genau das gleiche Schema.
Also, wir sind auf YouTube definitiv nicht besser, was das angeht.
Ja, ich sag Prank gone wrong gone sexual.
Oder echt wie sowas.
Schreiben die halt über 1000 Mal im Jahr über Helene Fischer
in irgendwelche Überschriften.
Und jetzt denkt ihr vielleicht, ist doch egal,
sollen die Promis das doch einfach ignorieren.
Aber zum einen verkaufen diese Magazine Millionen von Ausgaben.
Da werden Leute richtig reich mit Lügen.
Und viele Menschen glauben das am Ende halt auch.
Und zum anderen braucht es ja trotzdem Fotos und kleine Wahrheitsfitze,
um die man dann diese abstrusen Storys herumbauen kann.
Und das sorgt dafür, dass die Grundstücke von Promis belagert werden,
Paparazzi aus Hecken springen
und teilweise sogar private Mülltonnen durchsucht werden.
Im Falle von Thomas-
Ja, die haben schon Dachschaden.
aus seinem Podcast so oft von solchen Magazinen aus im Kontext gerissen,
dass er den Podcast deswegen beendet hat.
Jedes Mal, wie Thomas Gottschalk irgendwie aus Versehen
meine Frau statt meine Ex-Frau gesagt hat,
haben die da eine Titel-Story draus gemacht.
Thomas Gottschalk wieder zusammen mit seiner Frau, oh Gott.
Ein paar, was von dieser Belästigung am schlimmsten betroffen ist,
das sind Prince Harry und Meghan Markle.
Deswegen will ich gleich erzählen,
was in dem ganzen Jahr mit ihnen passiert ist.
Naja, dass es Leute kaufen heutzutage,
das sind die Leute, die das schon immer gekauft haben.
Die sind halt mittlerweile 50, eher 60 plus.
Die jüngere Generation, kann ich mir es nicht vorstellen,
die guckt sich aber den gleichen Click-Band-Scheiß auf YouTube an.
Zwar vom Inhalt her was anderes, aber ähnliche Masche.
Und ja, es mag sein, dass das in diesem Zeitschrift
noch ein Ticken heftiger ist als auf YouTube,
aber die hatten ja auch Zeit.
Das wird auf YouTube auch noch.
Moin, ja ich, vier Monate, da ich spiel jetzt ab.
Ich möchte rausfinden, was war alles in 2021 bei den Royals so los.
Und ich kann euch sagen, es ist wirklich abscheulich krass scheiße.
Bevor wir dazu kommen, kurz ein Wort von unserem Sponsor.
Mein Jahr war richtig scheiße.
Erst stand mein Sohn unter Mordverdacht
und dann sogar mein toter Ehemann.
Mein dunkles Geheimnis kam raus.
Dann hat mein Enkel mit mir abgerechnet und mich fast umgebracht.
Und dann ist sogar mein geheimes Testament geleakt.
Deswegen benutze ich jetzt die Clark App.
Das ist mein digitaler Versich...
Es ist wirklich Werbung.
Ich hab gedacht, es ist Fake Werbung.
Es ist wirklich echte Werbung.
Denn man weiß ja nie, was passiert.
Was, wenn die angeheiratete Enkel ran will an die Juwelen?
Dann ist es besser, wenn ich die versichert habe.
Deswegen habe ich all meine bestehenden Versicherungen
dort hochgeladen, um sie gut digital managen zu können.
Ich bin nämlich voll hipp.
Dieses Jahr war ein Auf und Ab für mich.
Erst kam die Wahrheit über meine Ehe raus, Ehekrise.
Mein Mann hat den Schlussstrich gezogen.
Er ist vor mir ins Ausland geflohen.
Weil er ein Doppelleben gelebt hatte.
Da habe ich direkt in der Clark App einen Bedarfscheck.
Ich konnte mit ihm einige glückliche Stunden verbringen.
Und dadurch, dass ich keinen Job mehr habe,
kamen mir die 45 Euro Amazon-Gutschein,
die ich mir mit dem Code ROBBUBBLE gesichert habe,
mehr als gelegen.
Da musste ich nur drei bestehende Versicherungen hochladen.
Das ist einfach Sellout mittendrinne.
Top.
Und weißt du was?
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Das Video ist jetzt zu 2 Drittel um.
Und es hat eigentlich vom Inhalt her, es ist noch nichts passiert.
Es ist eigentlich nur der Übersicht,
wie viele dieser Magazinen es gibt.
Und jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich,
jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich, was da drin ist.
Also, schieß los.
Wie war denn jetzt das vergangene Jahr von Harry und Meghan?
Das letzte Jahr endete erst mal damit,
dass Meghan rausfinden musste, dass Harry einen heimlichen Sohn hat.
Oh nein.
Die Freunde von Harrys Mutter Angst um sein Leben.
Ist Meghan etwa so wütend gewesen?
Doch dann im März hatte Harry wiederum Grund, selbst wütend zu sein.
Seine Kinder sind gar nicht von ihm.
Vielleicht sind sie ja von dem Hollywood-Star,
mit dem Meghan dann eine Affäre hatte.
Oder sind sie von ihrem Ex, der plötzlich zurück ist,
noch ein Schlag für Harry?
Oder ist es der Sohn seines Vaters?
Und jetzt gerade zum Ende des Jahres
kämpfen die beiden auch noch vor Gericht um ihre Kinder.
Und Leute, das war jetzt nur das,
was in einem der Magazinen übersiedelt wurde.
Das ist ja schon eine riesen Bullshit, Alter.
Bei der Prima Woche kam raus,
die beiden hatten schon im Januar eine Blitzscheidung.
Vielleicht, weil Harry rausgefunden hat,
dass sie die Fehlgeburt nur erfunden hat.
Oder waren es die skrupellosen Geschäfte
mit dem Erbe ihrer Mutter?
Da verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt,
warum die Queen ihr Hausverbot erteilt hat.
Auch bevor wir herausgefunden haben,
dass Meghan Harry zur Hochzeit nur gezwungen hat.
Und das, obwohl hier im September auch noch mal rauskam,
dass die Kinder gar nicht von Harry sind.
Und Harry ist gar kein Royal.
Er wurde nämlich bei der Geburt vertauscht.
Wisst ihr, was mich interessieren würde?
Wie sehen denn solche Zeitschriften von innen aus?
Ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt die Cover und so gesehen.
Sehen die innen genauso aus wie außen?
In der Prima Woche nimmt man jetzt die Stories
aus mehreren Magazinen zusammen.
Dann wird es noch aufregender.
Laut unseren 20 Magazinen kam es 2021 zu 8 Fällen,
bei denen Harry rausfütten musste,
dass sein Vater nicht sein Vater ist.
Oh nein.
Sondern einer von 3 unterschiedlichen Leuten,
die teilweise da rumgeschmissen wurden.
6 Mal kam raus, dass Harry selbst nicht der Vater
seiner eigenen Kinder ist.
Und insgesamt 25 Mal.
Und was ist das Fazit daraus?
Harry gibt es gar nicht, oder was?
Und zwar in fast jedem Monat.
Januar, Februar, März, April, im Mai.
Da haben sie sich wieder lieb gehabt.
Dann Juni, Juli, August.
September war wieder entspannt.
Alles aus.
Von diesen Scheidungen waren übrigens 5 Blitz-Scheidungen.
Das ist so ein Ding.
Da siehst du doch schon mal...
Das ist doch alles...
Das ist doch alles random Textbausteine generated, oder?
Ja.
Das benutzen die super gerne bei diesen Magazinen.
Blitz-Scheidungen.
Das sind halt einfach die Sachen, die sich gut verkaufen.
Und das sind sie schon seit Jahren.
Das erste Zeitschrift, die wir 2019 für die Tour gekauft haben,
von Lässerschwestern,
da stehen dieselben Sachen drauf.
Auch hier, Ehekrise, Harry und Meghan, sie wirft ihn aus dem Schlafzimmer.
Das ist immer das Gleiche.
Damit es aber trotzdem spannend bleibt,
damit die alten Leute, die es jetzt vielleicht schon zu 10 Mal gekauft haben,
trotzdem noch mal zuschlagen,
passieren dann ab und zu auch mal neue Sachen.
Zum Beispiel,
kanntet ihr schon die Wahrheit über Harrys Psychoguru?
Vielleicht hat er den,
weil er in Meghans Psycho-Hölle gefangen ist.
Ich meine...
Sie hat sogar eine Sekte gegründet.
Sie erpresst Harry mit einem Sex-Video.
Und Harry hat sie mit seinem Bruder betrogen.
Meghan das Beast,
nennen wir sie auch.
Sie erpresst sogar Kate. Und jetzt ist Harry krank.
Und daran ist auch nur Meghan schuld.
Dabei ist sie ja gar nicht mit Harry wirklich verheiratet,
denn die Hochzeit ist ungültig, weil sie bereits vorher schon einen Ehemann hatte.
Und dann gibt es auch noch häusliche Gewalt.
Kein Wunder,
dass das Kind schon mit zwei zur Therapie muss.
Um es nochmal zu betonen,
in diesem Video sind nur 20 von vermutlich
weit über 100 dieser Magazine.
Und ich hab natürlich auch nur die verrücktesten
Stories reingepackt. In Wirklichkeit sind Harry
und Meghan auf so gut wie jeder
zweiten Titelseite vermutlich sogar mehr.
Ja gut, die sind auf der Titelseite, weil da
scheiß ich mit denen da drauf wahrscheinlich gut verkauft.
Das ist der gleiche Grund,
warum
die Mobile Games Werbung nichts mit dem Inhalt
der Mobile Games zu tun hat.
Es bringt die Leute dazu, den Kram
sich zu holen.
Das ist natürlich nicht so wichtig, mich da auch nochmal drüber aufzuregen, weil ihr habt ja gerade gehört, Meghan wird da einfach fertig gemacht.
Und bei dem Autounfall, bei dem Harrys Mutter,
Prinzessin Diana, damals umgekommen ist,
war sie gerade auf der Flucht vor
Paparazzi. Und es gibt
Annahmen, dass der Grund für den Unfall war,
weil sie so schnell gefahren sind, um
vor dem Paparazzi zu entkommen.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum Prince Harry und Meghan
auf Versuch... Wisst ihr, was ich prinzipiell nicht
verstehe, ist, was
interessiert die Leute, dass eigentlich
so krass, was Helene Fischer und
Harry und Meghan machen.
Also ich weiß, dass die alle
existieren, aber was die machen,
geht mir komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Menschen mögen Drama, das ist richtig,
das ist das gleiche, warum Beef Videos auf
YouTube so gut ankommen. Und auch wenn uns vielleicht allen klar ist,
dass es Lügen sind, die da drin stehen,
macht es einen wahrscheinlich trotzdem ziemlich fertig,
die ganze Zeit Lügen über sich zu lesen
und auch von Menschen in der Öffentlichkeit
immer wieder darauf angesprochen zu werden,
weil es ja eine Menge Leute gibt, die denken,
dass was da drin steht, würde stimmen.
YouTube Beef geht auch immer gut.
Das ist absoluter Müll. Erzählt das eurer Oma,
falls ihr sie über die Feiertage seht.
Sagt der Oma, was liest das nicht?
Hier ist ein Kindl. Naht ihr das runter?
Ich habe auf jeden Fall eine Menge Spaß gehabt,
dieses Experiment jetzt endlich mal durchzuführen.
Okay, GG Eats.
Oh nee, warum geht es jetzt New World offen?
Es gibt ja kaum was Schlimmeres jetzt hier.
Erstmal Kindl ist sehr laut gewacht, genau.
So, haben wir sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Oh ja, er muss natürlich auch empfohlen werden.
Wir haben so viel Lego gekockt in letzter Zeit.
Da darf der Held der Steine natürlich nicht fehlen
in der Empfehlung.
Den habe ich übrigens zufällig mal
im Südbahnhof gesehen.
Aber gut, der kommt ja auch aus Frankfurt.
Oder hat zumindest einen Laden in Frankfurt.
Hast du mit dem getalkt so unter YouTuber?
Nö.
Gar nichts.
Ich weiß, wie ich nicht will, dass Leute mich in
Real Life erkennen und der hat bestimmt auch keinen Bock drauf.
Außerdem bin ich keiner, der random zu
irgendwelchen fremden Leuten geht.
Und YouTube Videos null.
Tja, irgendwie
gibt es ja gar nicht so viel, was YouTube uns
zeigen kann.
Teuer, aber flex.
Erinnerst du dich noch an die RTL-Reportage
zur Games? Natürlich erinnere ich mich da.
Ich habe da sogar
ein Video damals zugemacht.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, ja.
Das war die RTL-Reportage.
War doch das, wo sie auf die Gamescom
gegangen sind und dann random Leute
gefragt haben, und wie viele Mädchen
hast du heute schon angesprochen?
Und die Leute so, hä, alter, was wollt
ihr von mir?
Ist ja auch genau das Richtige,
ne? Also
wenn man gerade auf die Gamescom
fährt, das ist...
Aber
solche Reportage in dem
Ausmaß haben ja abgenommen.
Die letzten Jahre über. Es ist ja
auch klar, ich meine, Gaming ist heute so krass
Mainstream.
Das
ist nicht mehr
zu vergleichen mit vor 10 Jahren.
Die Leute verwenden heute unwissend
irgendwelche Game-Memes oder so.
Oh, Power-Style für den Sub.
Leute, ich muss
aufs Klo.
Richtig, richtig
Peepo-Pupu. Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt Stream aus.
Und vielleicht
komme ich nachher nochmal
an und wir basteln ein bisschen weiter mit...
Ach so, Chat, bevor ich gehe, Frage.
Müsst ihr morgen wieder arbeiten? Ja oder nein?
Also ich habe morgen noch frei.
Nein, nein, jo.
Ja, leider.
Homeoffice.
Ja, ich starte auch Dienstag mit Homeoffice,
weil ich gar keine Ahnung habe, was es überhaupt
für Regelungen bei uns gerade
gibt.
Muss ich mir erstmal angucken.
Urlaub.
Ja, perfekt.
Ich hatte jetzt Urlaub. Ich hatte jetzt eineinhalb Monate
Urlaub.
Seit dem
19.
Ich war seit dem 19.
November jetzt daheim.
Aber ich muss euch mal sagen, es ist gar nicht so ätzend
wie sonst.
Ich hatte immer überhaupt keinen Bock mehr
auf die Arbeit zu gehen,
wenn ich
dann wieder vier Tage nach Frankfurt
sollte. Aber somit
erstmal Homeoffice
und gucken, ist das nicht so schlimm.
Da muss ich nicht von nach eineinhalb Monaten
quasi
Selbstisolation wieder unter
Leute.
Ja.
Kannst du dann deinen Beruf
noch? Ich mache hier im Stream auch
nichts anderes.
Also jetzt nicht heute.
Nicht Aufwachstream, sondern
was wir so bei Technik Streams
machen. Das ist ja im Prinzip schon eng
mit dem verwandt, was ich auf der Arbeit auch so mache.
Dieses Yoshi-Bild macht
mich übelst fertig.
Der ist so fett, dass
er schon richtig schwabbelt.
So, wir haben jetzt
369 Zuschauer,
Leute.
Das ist der optimale
Zeitpunkt zu sagen. Ich gehe jetzt
aufs Klo und was fuddern.
Wir sehen uns, Leute. Vielleicht nachher
mache ich Stream noch mal an und dann basteln wir
ein bisschen weiter. Bis denn. Machts gut. See you.